Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Weißt du, was noch besser ist als PVC-Fitting, Klebemuffe, PVC-Muffe,
Rohrverbinder, Rohrschlauch, Klebefitting, Qualität aus Europa?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann diese Anfrage nicht erfüllen, da sie gegen die OpenRI-Nutzungsrichtlinie verstößt.
Mein Ziel ist es, den Nutzern hilfreiche und respektvolle Informationen zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 481 vom 14. Januar 2024.
Und da sind wir wieder im neuen Jahr. Neues Jahr.
Ja, ein neues Jahr.
Man denkt ja immer, dann ist immer alles auf Null zurückgestellt und dann wacht
man irgendwie auf und dann kommen schon die ersten Explosionen und Kleinkatastrophen
und Naturkatastrophen daher und man denkt sich so, naja okay,
so neu ist das jetzt nicht, oder?
Ja, vor allem, also alles auf Null bedeutet in dem Moment ja auch einfach nur
so, du bist gar nicht mehr im Negativen. Es kann nochmal ins Negative gehen.
Also alles auf Null ist gar nicht so gut.
Das stimmt. Ja, aber es gibt interessante neue Dinge, wie zum Beispiel dieses,
ich kann diese Anfrage nicht erfüllen, dass sie gegen die OpenAI-Nutzungsrichtlinie
verstößt. Da habe ich mir gleich zwei von gekauft.
Das ist ein super Produkt. Das ist ein Spitzenprodukt aus dem Hause OpenAI.
Und nicht mal aus Europa.
Qualität aus dem neuronalen Netzwerk. Wovon reden wir?
Ich meine, das ist ja nichts Neues. Wer in den letzten Jahren mal bei Amazon
geblättert hat, da finden ja schon die merkwürdigsten Dinge statt.
Und neben diesem ganzen SEO-Kram, wo man sich immer denkt, was die sich immer
wieder alles einfallen lassen, merkt man mittlerweile, die lassen sich das gar
nicht einfallen, die lassen sich das mittlerweile auch generieren.
Das schlägt dann manchmal fehl und dann stehen halt tatsächlich bei Amazon.com
so Produkte, wo quasi diese OpenAI-Fehlermeldung drin steht. It happened.
Das ist ja auch schon so ein, also da gibt es, das ist ja schon viele Jahre
alt, da gab es glaube ich irgendwie auch so einen Messestand von einem,
ich kann, leider kann ich nicht sagen, ob das jetzt chinesisches oder japanisches
Unternehmen war oder was auch immer, die halt groß ihren Satz da stehen hatten,
ja, und darunter dann den in Englisch stehen haben wollten, da stand dann einfach
Translation Engine Error. Ja, genau.
Sehr schön. Tja, Lorem Ipsum war gestern.
Ja, das ist halt der klassische, oh ja, Translate Server Error.
Und als goldene Türschilder und was, da gibt es richtig schöne,
wenn man sich da mal Bilder, Bilderchen sucht bei der Suchmaschine der Wahl.
Produkte gibt es auch, Translate Server Error Produkte.
Restaurants, die so heißen.
Ja, aber es gibt auch gute Nachrichten. Also zum Beispiel die Rohrpostanlage
im Kanzleramt bleibt weiter in Betrieb.
Wusstest du das?
Ja, da verstehe ich nicht genau, was daran, das war auch irgendwie Thema, ne?
Es war beim Spiegel eine Meldung wert.
Ja, es war auch denen heute eine Push-Notification wert, dass Dänemark einen neuen König hat.
Ja, gut.
Ich meine, solange der nicht durch eine gewaltsame Umsturz da in diese Position
gekommen ist, ist das doch keine Push-Nachricht.
Ja gut, du weißt ja, der Boulevard. Aber ich fand das ganz interessant,
weil ich hatte natürlich keine
Ahnung, dass es überhaupt noch eine Rohrpostanlage gibt im Kanzleramt.
Ich dachte auch, geil.
Ja, dachte ich auch so. Und tatsächlich, also laut diesem Artikel gibt es so
rein tausend Sendungen, die über diese Rohrpostanlage übermittelt werden.
Und jetzt bleibt die auch erstmal im Betrieb. Das hatten sie wohl mal so als,
das müsste jetzt langsam mal wegkommen, weil wir haben ja Computer.
Und das haben sie so festgestellt, so mit den Computern und so.
Schwierig, ne? Und um jetzt weitere Spionage zu verhindern oder nicht ohne weiteres
zu ermöglichen, arbeitet man halt weiter mit Rohrpost.
Also ich würde mir eher darüber Gedanken machen, was für Drucker man da stehen hat.
Also mal ganz im Ernst, so die Sicherheit von Druckern, also hoffentlich drucken
die noch irgendwie mit so einem alten Nadeldrucker oder so.
Aber ich weiß jetzt auch ganz ehrlich gesagt nicht, wenn du jetzt so eine E-Mail
ausdruckst und dann in die Rohrpost tust,
ob das jetzt gerade noch einen Sicherheitsgewinn darstellt oder nicht.
Ja, also Drucker ist wirklich ein guter Punkt.
Ich meine, wenn man sich dann immer so irgendwo mal eine WLAN-Liste kommen sieht,
sitzt in irgendeinem Café und dann siehst du halt immer so, ja hallo,
ich bin das WLAN von diesem Brother Drucker.
Ich bin hier gerade von irgendjemandem aufgestellt worden und habe hier so mein
Default-Netz aufgemacht, damit du da irgendwie schnell mal drucken kannst.
Das sind alles natürlich solche offenen Wunden und es gibt sicherlich auch schon
zahlreiche erfolgreiche Hacks, um diese doch relativ einfachen Betriebssysteme
dieser Printer aufzumachen.
Und wenn dann halt da irgendwie so eine kleine Malware schlummert,
dann kann sie das dann einfach direkt absaugen und im Idealfall auch gleich weitersenden.
Du, das ist eine Katastrophe. Ich habe hier einen Brother-Drucker.
Bei Druckern kann ich nur Brother-Drucker ernst nehmen.
Alles andere kannst du komplett vergessen. Also unter der Annahme,
dass du einen Drucker willst, der druckt.
Dann kannst du eigentlich nur mit Brother dich in dieses Abenteuer wagen.
Allerdings ist, ich habe sogar zwei davon, und der eine, der hat irgendwie einen
Telnet-Port, den kannst du auch nicht abstellen.
Und da ist unauthenticated irgendwie Zugang über Telnet, so das geht auch nicht
weg, ja, das heißt du musst denen dann irgendwie ein eigenes Netzwerksegment stellen,
wo du den weg firewallst, damit dir keiner auf den Telnet-Port geht und das
ist natürlich für die meisten Leute….
Hast du mal draufconnected?
Da kommt so eine, also ich kann das jetzt gerade nicht ausprobieren,
weil ich das natürlich irgendwie weggemacht habe, also den weggefeuert habe,
aber da kam irgendein Telnet-Menü oder so, ich weiß nicht, ob da eine Shell
kommt, aber irgendwie sowas.
Also Telnet, für Leute, die nicht wissen, was das ist,
Telnet ist so ein uralt, also so ein richtig,
richtig vom Anfang vom Internet das aller, aller, allererste Protokoll,
um sich einfach auf einem anderen Rechner einzuloggen und das ist sozusagen ein Nicht-Protokoll.
Telnet ist einfach die direkte Verbindung zwischen deinem Rechner und dem anderen
Rechner, die dann üblicherweise immer auf so einem Login aufschlug.
Also es ist sozusagen über das Netz einfach ein Terminal, als würde man sozusagen
direkt mit der Tastatur am Rechner sitzen.
Und das ist irgendwie keine gute Idee, sowas offen zu haben,
ohne irgendwelche Verschlüsselungen und sonstigen Authentifizierungen.
Braucht man ja eigentlich auch nicht für einen Drucker.
Genau, es ist SSH ohne S und naja, SH gab es ja auch und noch davor, also,
üblicherweise irgendein Terminal-Programm oder so kann man dann da rein,
aber das willst du nicht willst du nicht, also brauchst du auch nicht an deinem
Drucker und vor allem brauchst du das nicht an deinem Drucker und,
nicht abschaltbar ja, so, du machst dann irgendwelche Sicherheit auf dem Drucker
und dann kann jeder über Telnet reingehen oder wieder wegmachen Ich hätte ganz
gerne eine Rohrpost von meinem Drucker wiederum an meinen Schreibtisch.
Da muss man dann nicht immer hinrennen und das Ding machen. Da kannst du ja
ausdrucken und dann gleich in so einem Röhrchen verschießen. Das wäre doch nett.
Ich habe es auf jeden Fall, also natürlich ist Rohrpost eine unterhaltsame Anlage.
Also auf CCC Kongressen ja auch seit wie vielen Jahren? Gab es dieses Jahr gar nicht?
Ne, mittlerweile, es gab es glaube ich auch schon letztes Mal nicht mehr.
War das so?
Ja, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, vielleicht gab es noch lokal eine kleine Anlage,
aber die Novelty has worn off, das war mal eine super Sache.
War eine Zeit lang echt lustig, diese Drainagerohre aus dem,
wo benutzt man die, Landschaftsbau oder?
Also Straßenbau, so diese gelben Rohre, die du so bei den Autobahnen an der
Seite siehst, wo das Wasser abgeleitet wird.
So was ist relativ günstig zu bekommen.
Und sagen wir mal so, es gab schon Begeisterung dafür.
Das Problem ist nur, dass auf solchen Veranstaltungen diese Rohrverlegung ein
wenig an dem Konzept der Feuertürtrennung scheitert.
Also du kannst halt nicht von Raum zu Raum gehen.
Aber dafür hat der liebe Gott uns den Kernbohrer geschenkt.
Naja, aber das durften wir dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Ist halt schwierig mit
so automatisch schließenden Türen, wenn du da so ein Drainagerohr die ganze
Zeit drin rumhängen kannst.
Da kommt so die Feuerwehr und sagt einfach nur Leute, ihr habt Humor.
Dabei kann man das ja super als Entrauchungsanlage dann direkt weiter anwenden.
Super, ja, ja, okay, das funktioniert. Das ist tolles Engineering,
viele Grüße von Bea. Also, naja.
Also die Rohrpostanlage, es ist schon ein Relikt aus einer Zeit,
also wo du denkst, ich meine, kurze Frage, diese Rohrpostanlage ist schon lokal,
oder haben die da internationales Routing?
Du meinst, ob man sich da anschließen kann?
Weil dann kann ja sein, dass da irgendwie so eine...
Naja, ich meine, Berlin hat eine große Rohrpostanlagen-Vergangenheit.
Also Rohrpostanlagen waren lange, lange Zeit in Berlin, sicherlich auch in anderen
Städten. Ich weiß es jetzt nur von Berlin.
Also vor 100 Jahren gab es sowas noch.
Das war quasi so ein Telegram-Interface innerhalb der Stadt.
Also um schnell Nachrichten zu versenden, war Rohrpost tatsächlich a thing.
Gibt, glaube ich, sogar noch hier, wenn du bei Berliner Unterwelten mal klickst,
das ist ja hier so eine Organisation, die dich durch Bunker und allerlei sonstige Anlagen schickt.
Da war meines Wissens auch immer noch die alte Rohrpostanlage dabei.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob die jetzt noch existiert, weil da so viel neu gebaut
wurde in dieser Gegend. Also ich bin mir gerade jetzt nicht so sicher.
Aber ich finde Rohrpost auch toll und vor allem gab es dann ja später in Büros
auch wirklich so mit Autorouting und so weiter.
Das heißt, man hat so die Adresse an der Rohrpost selber selber eingestellt
und dann ist es immer in so Weichen vorbeigeglitten, wo dann automatisch gelesen
wurde, ist das jetzt für hier?
Und dann haben die sozusagen an der richtigen Stelle abgezweigt.
Also das war jetzt nicht nur so eine AB-Verbindung, sondern das war dann schon
ein relativ intelligentes Routing.
Ja, tolle Technik.
Wahnsinn. Ja.
Also Bundeskanzleramt offiziell retro. Aber wo wir gerade bei Produktempfehlungen,
sind, jenseits der Klebemuffen.
Ich hatte auch in der letzten Sendung so nebenbei Regenschirme empfohlen.
Ohne da groß was zu sagen. Du hattest glaube ich ein Regenschirmproblem.
Haben wir da Gelbte bekommen?
Nee.
Warum willst du denn unbedingt darüber reden?
Wir machen gar keine Werbung.
Achso, wir reden über Logbuch-Regenschirme. Ja gut, also was sind das denn?
Was für Regenschirme empfiehlst du?
Weil du kanntest das glaube ich nicht.
Nee, kannte ich auch tatsächlich nicht.
Sens-Regenschirme, ist das bekannt? Sens-Regenschirme sind ganz toll.
Weil Sens-Regenschirme sind nicht rund, sondern Sens-Regenschirme sind so asymmetrisch geformt.
Und das sieht halt einerseits sehr spacig aus, hat aber diesen Riesenvorteil,
dass die Dinger durch diese Form extrem umklappfest sind.
Also du kannst da sozusagen auch im Cabrio das Ding aufmachen und bei voller Fahrt benutzen.
Also du hast natürlich immer noch den Drag sozusagen, aber die klappen dann nicht um.
Und die haben einfach eine geile Stabilität. Einerseits.
Andererseits haben die auch so eine geile kinetische Automatik,
weil wenn du den sozusagen schließt, die Kraft, die du dann da rein investierst, die wird dann halt,
in dem Teil gespeichert und wenn du dann auf Knopf drückst, dann faltet der
sich dann auch automatisch wieder aus und das ist halt einfach cool.
Aber Tim, ist das Geheimnis vielleicht eine Feder?
Jaja, klar, aber das ist einfach gut.
Weil du jetzt irgendwie so, die Kraft wird gespeichert.
Jaja, in einer Feder. Na klar wird die in einer Feder gespeichert.
Das machen andere Regenschirme aber auch.
Es funktioniert besonders gut bei diesem Sense, kann ich dir nur sagen.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein Produkt, was begeistert, wenn ihr also glücklich sein
sein wollt, dann ist das meine Empfehlung.
Ja, dann mache ich das jetzt sofort auf meine Wunschliste. Ich will einen Regenschirm.
Schenken, ne?
Regenschirm?
Ist okay.
35 Euro Regenschirm lasse ich mir lieber schenken, ja. Da bin ich ganz ehrlich. Gut.
Pure Black Reflective.
Ah, es gibt auch einen für doppelt so viel. Dann nehmen wir den.
Es gibt in verschiedenen Größen XL, so wie Blechenschirmer und so, volles Programm.
Toll, alles super. Okay.
Ja, und wenn ich ein bisschen hallig klinge, dann hat das damit zu tun, dass ich hier gerade,
gerade so auf einer Studienreise bin, um mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
wie das eigentlich so ist mit dem Faschismus.
Wie sich das so anfühlt. Weil man muss sich ja schon ein bisschen warm machen.
Nicht in alle Situationen immer so unvorbereitet reinlaufen.
Weil das ist ja jetzt in meiner Vergangenheit, kannte ich das ja nicht,
da habe ich ja noch in so einem freiheitlichen Land mit aktiver Demokratie und
hoher Wahlbeteiligung gelebt.
Da dachte ich mir so, guckst du mal, wie das ist. Dann bin ich nach Budapest gefahren.
Bevor du jetzt Fremder im eigenen Land wirst, bereitest du dich schon mal auf den Faschismus vor.
Genau. Man sieht das dann auch gleich. Das fand ich dann doch sehr überraschend,
wie das so funktioniert.
Ganz subtil. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite hast du hier so europäische Stadt,
alles ganz hübsch irgendwie, super gepflegt, tolle alle City,
Häuser und so, auch alles nicht so bombenzerstört, das macht ja schon mal was aus.
Und dann gehst du so durch die Straßen und dann ist da so wirklich so,
die ganze Straße runter, in regelmäßigen Abstand stehen so Litfaßsäulen und
an diesen Litfaßsäulen prangt dann ein bekanntes Gesicht,
nämlich das von Ursula von der Leyen.
Mit einem mir, gemeinsam noch mit einem mir weniger bekannten Gesicht,
aber um wen es sich dabei handelt, wird auch allen sofort erklärt,
weil das steht sozusagen drunter, also Ursula von der Leyen und die andere Person ist Alex Soros,
also der Sohn von George Soros, der jetzt diese Soros Foundation übernommen hat.
Und wer den Kontext nicht kennt, Soros ist ja Ungar und ist mal durch interessante
Aktionen auf dem Finanzmarkt sehr reich geworden und hat sein ganzes Geld in
diese Soros Foundation gesteckt,
die für Gutes tut, weltweit so.
Aber er ist natürlich auch jüdischen Ursprungs und dann trifft ihn natürlich
hier auch im eigenen Land.
Die volle Breitseite von Antisemitismus und überhaupt Leute,
die sich für Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit und Demokratie einsetzen,
sind dann eh etwas suspekt, zumindest Herrn Orban.
Also prangen irgendwie überall diese Plakate, wo also diese beiden Personen,
also es ist kein gemeinsames Foto, sondern es ist sozusagen so eine Montage,
wo die einfach so nebeneinander abgebildet sind und dann steht halt der Name darunter.
Und dann steht da so in Ungarisch darunter etwas, was ich mir jetzt nur habe
automatisch übersetzen lassen.
Also auf Englisch ist es so ein bisschen so Do not dance the way they feel.
Oder auf Deutsch, tanzt nicht.
Tanzt nicht nach ihrer Nase oder so?
Ja, also das kann ich jetzt ein bisschen. Es scheint mir so ein bisschen auch
so eine umgangssprachliche Variante zu sein.
Also ich beherrsche natürlich kein Ungarisch. Das macht, glaube ich,
außer Ungarn auch keiner, weil das ist einfach mal eine Sprache,
die ist einfach mal anders als alle anderen.
Aber ich deute das jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen nach diesem Motto.
So wie die das machen, ist das nicht gut für euch. So will ich das mal sagen. Also ganz klare,
antieuropäische, antisemitische Sprache. Und das steht dann einfach so kommentarlos
auf diesen Litfaßsäulen.
Die komplette Litfaßsäule, nur dieses eine Motiv. Und dann halt so fünf,
sechs, sieben Litfaßsäulen, die ganze Hauptstraße herunter durchgehen. Nur dieses Motiv.
Keine Werbung, kein irgendwas anderes oder so. Nur diese Botschaft.
Und das ist so, ich weiß nicht, Das hat mich so total an Brasil erinnert.
Und diese ganzen Fake-Faschoposters, die da irgendwie auch drin sind.
Eagle Eyes can save a life.
Das ist schon irgendwie absurd.
Das ist halt so eine subtile,
Beeinflussung. Und man merkt das auch. Ich habe mich dann irgendwie mit Leuten
unterhalten. Wie seht ihr denn das hier mit der Ukraine?
Und dann merkst du, dass die Leute auf der einen Seite, ja, so Orban ist ja
eigentlich gar nicht so gut, aber was die Ukraine da macht, das ist ja auch
nicht so und dann, die foltern ja die Russen und so.
Also die ganze Propaganda sickert dann dann einfach doch irgendwo ein.
Wer ist denn die Urheberin dieser Plakate? Ist das dann die Regierung oder ist das die?
Also Also da steht da auch nicht drauf.
Also ich meine, es ist schon klar, wer der Urheber ist, weil ich glaube nicht,
dass irgendjemand außer der Regierung in der Lage wäre,
so etwas ohne Zustimmung der Regierung dort so plakativ unterzubringen.
Also das ist schon sehr offensichtlich.
Ja, also ich bin jetzt auch erst gestern angekommen. Das ist jetzt keine besonders
umfangreiche Einschätzung der Situation hier, aber das stach einem dann doch sofort ins Auge.
Also es war einfach komplett unübersehbar und überall, also nicht nur eine Straße, überall.
Echt krass. Da drunter steht noch irgendwas hier. Das müsste ich mir nochmal übersetzen.
NEMZI-Konsultation. Ja, mal gucken, was das vielleicht heißen könnte.
Irgendwie Beratung nimmt sie die Beratung keine Ahnung, vielleicht irgendeine Agentur,
So eine Fake-Agentur.
Naja. Also demnächst dann in ihrem Kino.
Da müssen wir nicht aufpassen.
Tja, wir waren, ich habe jetzt hier, wir zeichnen ja am Sonntag auf den 14. Januar.
Ich war tatsächlich,
vorher bei dieser Anti-AfD-Demo. Also einer der vielen. Inzwischen gibt es ja sehr viele.
Pariser Platz. Also der Ort, nicht der Imperativ. Brandenburger Tor.
Jetzt nicht dazu hinreißt, die Zahlen zu schätzen, aber das war schon einige tausend Leute.
Da passen einige hin, auf jeden Fall.
Da passen einige hin, ja. Und,
Ja, war ganz erfrischend zu sehen, dass sich jetzt mal langsam die Leute darüber
Gedanken machen mit dieser Partei.
Wichtiger ist ja immer zu sehen, wer ist eigentlich da. Also ich meine,
wenn das so ein bisschen die üblichen Verdächtigen aus dem schwarzen Block waren,
dann hat es glaube ich… Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nee, nee, nee, eher gar nicht.
Also das war eher so die bürgerliche Mitte, wie man das so schön sagt.
Merkte man auch daran, dass die Versuche der Rednerinnen oder einiger Rednerinnen zu, sagen wir mal,
szenisch typischen Sprechchören aufzufordern, nicht so funktioniert hat.
Ja, hat nicht so gegriffen.
Ja, okay.
So mit This is what democracy looks like oder ganz Berlin hasst die AfD.
Das hat alles nicht so verfangen.
Das ist gut. Das gefällt mir. Das ist gut.
Erstmal ist das ein gutes Zeichen, weil das bedeutet, dass nicht die gleiche
Suppe da ist, die jeden Tag da steht. So, ne?
Genau. Genau, also sehr, das ist positiv.
Nicht Antifa Allstars, sondern irgendwie die neue Mitte.
Da war die Mitte der Gesellschaft so vertreten.
In allem, was sie ausmacht.
Auch vielleicht eine Demonstration Unerfahrenheit, gleichzeitig aber auch Kreativität
und individuelle Gestaltung,
Gestaltung bei der Demonstrationsplakat beim Demonstrationsplakatbau und natürlich auch dann Parteien,
die sich dann da mit ihrem Merch ankommen und da dann Bilder machen für Social
Media und all was da so dazugehört.
Und das brauchst du eben, die musst du eben auch alle dann da haben.
Welche Parteien waren das?
Mir sind aufgefallen die Linke
und die Grüne. CDU habe ich nirgendwo gesehen, Werteunion auch nicht.
Und ich glaube, ich hatte eine SPD-Person gesehen, die hat irgendwie so ein
DPA-Interview gegeben.
Also die SPD war wahrscheinlich auch da.
Also FDP, AfD, CDU, CSU sind mir da nicht aufgefallen. Das kann aber auch heißen,
dass die einfach am anderen Ende standen.
Ich habe da jetzt nicht alles gesehen. Also ich will jetzt keine Aussage darüber
treffen, welche Partei da war oder welche nicht.
Vielleicht hat die SPD erst noch den Wind gemessen, damit sie wissen,
wo sie ihre Fahne aufhängen kann.
Das kann sehr gut sein, in welchen Wind man jetzt die Fahne hängen muss,
kann natürlich sein, aber ja, also es war erstmal primär sind da einfach Menschen
gewesen, die ganz offensichtlich jetzt nicht aus irgendwelchen,
organisierten Gruppen kamen.
Normale Menschen, die keinen Bock auf Nazis haben.
Genau.
Ja.
Schön, dann könnten wir ja langsam mal anfangen hier mit unserer Sendung. Was hältst du davon?
Schuldfähigkeit. Eine Schuldfähigkeit kann ab 14 festgestellt werden.
Unter den Bedingungen des Risikos
auf schwere Straftaten kann man eine Unterbringung nach § 63 anordnen.
Das ist eine forensische Psychiatrie.
Hat aber nichts mit Sicherungsverwahrung zu tun, das ist nämlich quasi das,
was ich erklärt habe, dass man jemanden in quasi haftähnlichen Bedingungen hält,
weil man davon ausgeht, dass er noch gefährlich ist.
Das, was jetzt hier benannt wird als die Unterbringung nach Paragraf 63,
da wird jährlich geprüft und während dieser Unterbringung läuft eine Therapie.
Also es ist eine Zwangstherapie in Abgrenzung von Sicherungsverwahrung.
Ein Fall wie in England wäre darunter kaum vorstellbar.
Jetzt kommt natürlich das erschwerende Problem dazu, dass in England natürlich
andere Gesetze gelten, was meine Erklärung jetzt auch nicht deutlich einfacher
gemacht hat. Die Dauer der Unterbringung richtet sich nach dem Therapiefortschritt.
Man kann zum Beispiel nach einem Mord nach drei Jahren auf freiem Fuß sein,
bei einer Brandstiftung nach
zehn Jahren noch drin sein, weil die Gefährlichkeit weiterhin besteht.
Wer sich fragt, wer dort ist, über 80 Prozent Schizophrenie,
ansonsten bipolare Störungen, Intelligenzminderungen und so weiter. Weiter.
Sicherungsverwahrung nach Paragraf 66 StGB ist etwas ganz anderes.
Die erfolgt nicht stadthaft wie Paragraf 63, sondern im Anschluss an die Haft.
Hierfür muss keine Krankheit vorliegen, sondern eine hohe Gefährlichkeit.
Da findet man in erster Linie Sexualstraftäter. Hatte ich, glaube ich,
auch so ungefähr wiedergegeben.
Also entscheidend ist, 63 ist im Prinzip eine Einweisung in eine Psychiatrie,
wo man quasi auch nach erfolgreicher Therapie dann rauskommt.
Sicherungsverwahrung wäre im Anschluss an eine Haft.
Das ist der Kernunterschied.
Alright. Dann kam was zu geil.
Luki Puki schreibt uns, geil, a blast from the past.
Die 90er haben angerufen und wollen ihre Untergang des Abendlandes Diskussion wieder zurück.
Ich bin nun 37 und habe das Anfang Mitte der 90er mitbekommen,
wie Deutschland geiler wurde sozusagen. Das erste Mal gehört habe ich es von
meinem Nachbarn und ist danach jahrelang nur gleichbedeutend zu toll gekannt und benutzt.
Dass dieses Wort irgendwie im Generationskonflikt einen besonderen Platz hatte,
merkte ich, weil sich meine Oma regelmäßig echauffierte. Geil,
geil, geil. Alles ist bei euch immer so geil.
Sie hatte damals 30 Jahre in der politischen Redaktion einer damals noch echt
guten Zeitung gearbeitet und
fand das wahrscheinlich ähnlich dufte wie die Verfasserin von Linus Mail.
Oder lass uns mal ehrlich sein, das war doch garantiert ein Verfasser. Oder?
So viel Elan und Mühe in so eine singuläre alberne Geschichte zu investieren,
machen doch nur echte männliche Flachpfeifen. Meine Oma hat sich allerdings
irgendwann damit abgefunden und sich einfach darüber amüsiert.
Aber erstaunlich, der Mail-Verfasser muss meiner Intuition nach älter als 80 sein.
Geistig auf jeden Fall Übrigens in dieser Mail stand ja auch drin sie möge bitte
ausgedruckt und mir zugeschickt werden, um sie dann meiner Rohrpost zuzuführen,
und es ist passiert, ich hab es bekommen, ich hab's dir ja geschickt auch noch mit natürlich,
wo ich da denke, da müsste man sich mal irgendwie auch Gedanken drüber machen
So mit einigen Wörtern größer, wo dann größere Schrift ist und fett und unterstrichen und so.
Das volle Programm.
Und das ging, habe ich dann auch festgestellt, CC an den Verein Deutsche Sprache. Der...
Ja genau, den Schnuller-Nazis irgendwie, oh man ey.
Die auch wahrscheinlich. Ich meine, der Verein Deutscher Sprache,
die Vorsitzende des Vereins Deutscher Sprache ist ja eher damit beschäftigt,
in irgendwelchen Hinterzimmern die Deportationspläne von Martin Selvner zu besprechen.
Aber ich finde es schön, dass sie dann sich jetzt auch noch mal damit auseinandersetzen
müssen, welche Vokabeln ich verwende im ZDF.
Beim Verein für Deutsche Sprache finden die gar nichts geil,
so richtig, habe ich den Eindruck.
Ja, das sind ja eh nur Wahlen heute. Dann gab es noch Feedback, Wahlen.
Richtig, supergeil schreibt, Europawahl steht an ihr Banhausen.
Haben wir nämlich vergessen zu erwähnen, werden so glaube ich diverse Wahlen aufgezählt, aber klar,
dieses Jahr ist auch Europawahl und auch da sind wir wieder mal gespannt, wie das wohl so ausgeht.
Und weißt du, was auch ist?
Na?
Berlin-Wahl. Ich habe eine Wahlbenachrichtigung bekommen.
Oh ja, ich auch. Ja, ich bin auch betroffen.
Ich darf auch nochmal. Once more with feeling. Ja, am 11. Februar muss ich da nochmal hin.
Genau, also Hintergrund für wen das jetzt wird, ihr werdet es vielleicht am
Rande mitbekommen haben, aber in Berlin fand ja Das habe ich dir doch erzählt, da war ich,
Moment, doch, da war ich.
Doch, ja klar, 21, 26.09.21. Bei der Wahl habe ich ja mitgewahlhelfert.
Das hatte ich hier in der Sendung auch erzählt, dass das ein bisschen wild war. Ja, genau.
Aber das war nicht dein eigenes Wahllokal, wo du selber gewählt hast, ne?
Nee, meine Stimme habe ich nicht wiedergefunden. Nee, ich habe mal ein anderes,
einen anderen Ort ausgezählt, ja.
Okay, aber da ist es dann noch schlechter gelaufen. Genau, also ich war auch so voll im Chaosbezirk.
Hauptgrund, also der Hauptgrund war, dass es alles scheiße organisiert war und
so ein Nebeneffekt, der das dann alles verschlimmert war, war, dass irgendwie,
man die Bundestagswahl dann eben genau mit dem selben Wochenende zusammengelegt
hat, wo der Berlin-Marathon stattfindet oder andersrum, man hat den Berlin-Marathon
wie auch immer auf jeden Fall, das hat nicht so gut gepasst,
weil dann die ganzen unter, mit Wahlzetteln unter versorgten,
sag ich fast Filialen gesagt, Wahllokale, dann nicht mehr rechtzeitig beschickt
werden konnten, weil dann die Kuriere nicht durchkamen. Es ist einfach alles wirklich...
Die Folge, in der wir das besprochen haben, ist die LMP 408 mit dem schönen
Titel Führung in der Wurstfabrik, in der wir außerdem, weil ja dann gerade die
Bundestagswahl war, den Flyerservice Hahn besprechen.
Ach, guck an.
Genau, die Führung in der Wurstfabrik habe ich da gemacht. Die habe ich da hinter mich gebracht.
Die haben mich auch nochmal angefragt, jetzt als Wahlhelfer,
aber ich habe gedankend abgelehnt.
Also super nett, voll lieb von euch, aber versucht mal selber hinzukriegen.
Ja, okay, gut. Führung der Wurstfabrik, da gucke ich doch gleich,
machen wir da schon ein Transkript? Ja, haben wir schon.
Ich sehe ja zu, dass irgendwie alte Sendungen, auf die wir verweisen,
falls sie noch noch kein transkript haben dann hole ich das immer nach stück
für stück das ist super super lieb.
Ich weiß ja, als erstes Thema könnten
wir ja mal ganz kurz noch über die Vertreibungspläne der AfD sprechen.
Das Thema behandeln wir relativ schnell, weil wir es in der nächsten Woche etwas
ausführlicher behandeln möchten.
Das ist der Plan.
Das ist unser Masterplan.
Es ist der investigativen Rechercheplattform Korrektiv gelungen,
ein geheimes, nicht öffentliches Treffen von Werteunion,
Identitärer Bewegung, AfD und einer Reihe irgendwelcher Leute,
deren Qualifikation primär darin besteht, reich und faschistisch zu sein.
Zu dokumentieren, indem Pläne für massenhafte Deportationen aus Deutschland geschmiedet werden.
Und diese Veröffentlichung, also dieses Treffen hat glaube ich im November stattgefunden,
es wurde jetzt Anfang Januar veröffentlicht und es hat dann doch sehr großen
Impact gehabt, wie wir gerade auch schon an der Demonstration,
die ich da mal besucht habe, gesehen haben.
Und es wird gerade sehr ausführlich diskutiert, dass es sich bei der AfD um
eine verfassungsfeindliche Partei handelt. Und die Forderung nach einem AfD-Verbot wird immer lauter.
Unseren Gast Stefan wird es sicherlich freuen, der ja mit dem Zentrum für politische
Schönheit in dieser Richtung seit einigen Wochen auch Forderungen stellt.
Wir haben in den Shownotes eine Verbots, wie heißt das denn hier,
wenn man online, jetzt fehlt mir gerade das Wort.
Petition.
Petition, genau. Und ein paar Links dazu und werden das Thema,
denke ich, hier noch ausführlicher besprechen.
Nicht nur in der nächsten Sendung, sondern auch wiederholend.
Denn ich denke, dass wir uns wirklich gerade mal überlegen müssen,
wann wir bei dieser Krise an dem Kipppunkt sind,
wo man den nicht mehr los wird.
Ja, und ich habe auch so ganz grundsätzlich, sieht man ja gerade in der Diskussion,
dass jetzt bei der, also das AfD-Verbot wird jetzt auch hier wieder in der Mitte
der Gesellschaft diskutiert, ja,
einen sehr guten Kommentar von Heribert Prantl kürzlich gehört im Deutschlandfunk,
der eben auch sagt, sie wurden jetzt lange genug unterschätzt und mit dieser Unterschätzung.
Werden sie nicht weniger gefährlich. Und teilweise gibt es ja auch krasse Reaktionen
von AfD-Vertretern, die also sagen, Moment, das mit den massenhaften Deportationen,
ist kein Geheimplan, sondern das ist unser Versprechen.
Das ist schon ziemlich, ziemlich krass, wie offen, die sich jetzt auch in dieser Thematik zeigen.
Und ich denke, da ist jetzt der Moment, wo sich entscheidet,
wo sie ihre Maske fallen lassen und auch sagen, ja klar, wollen wir hier alle rauswerfen.
Natürlich sind wir eine faschere Partei, die schicken wir alle nach Afrika.
Und unabhängig davon, ob die da... Also ich fände das auch ehrlich gesagt jetzt
erstmal schwierig, wenn ich nach Afrika verschleppt werde.
Also für mich wäre das, da müsste ich mich erstmal drauf einstellen und damit
auch mit der Situation umgehen in irgendeinem Land, in dem ich eventuell noch
nie war, dessen Sprache ich nicht spreche.
Also da stellt sich auch die Frage, ob ich da überhaupt integrationswillig bin.
Muss man sich ja auch mal überlegen. Aber okay.
Das Thema wird jetzt diskutiert und ich denke, das ist jetzt wirklich ein Point of no return.
Hören, weil wenn diese Diskussion jetzt in die falsche Richtung kippt und diese
Partei bestehen bleibt, dann haben wir wirklich eine Wiederholung der Geschichte
und ich fände das relativ gut, wenn wir das nicht hätten.
Ja, schauen wir mal, wie es läuft, aber ich bin schon mal ganz zufrieden,
dass zumindest ein paar Leute jetzt aufwachen und merken, dass das ein echtes
Problem ist und nicht nur eine Annoyance.
Ja,
Okay, mehr in den nächsten Sendungen. Genau.
So, dann gab es noch eine Veranstaltung, den 37. Chaos Communication Kongress.
Endlich, endlich wieder Kongress.
Man merkt dann auch, wie sehr man das eigentlich vermisst hat.
Also mir ging es zumindest so.
In Hamburg, nach vier Jahren Pause und nicht nur einem Jahr wie sonst,
Sonst gab es dann mal die Veranstaltung wieder.
Wollen wir noch mehr dazu sagen?
Es war natürlich großartig, das wieder stattfinden zu lassen, das CCH in neuem Gewand.
Wobei ich auch teilweise, ich glaube an einigen Stellen lag noch der alte Teppich,
den ich schon damals irgendwie ein bisschen Old Age fand. aber eine gelungene... Bitte? Fandst du geil?
Teppich ist eins der absoluten Superfeatures dieser Location.
Dass du einfach überall dich einfach mal so hinsetzen kannst,
auf dem Boden rumgammeln kannst und so weiter. Das ist ein Riesenfeature.
Also ich bin kein Freund von Teppich.
Ich muss das ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich finde Teppich...
Teppich ist einfach nicht meine Welt.
Was ist die Alternative? Die Alternative ist Steinboden oder Parkett.
Parkett.
Ja, und da spürst du jeden Dreckkrümel, da ist es kalt. Es ist einfach nicht
schön, es ist nicht flauschig.
Ja, aber dafür hängt da nicht der kalte Siff drin.
Da sind die ganze Zeit Leute mit einem Staubsauger durch die Gegend gerannt.
Ja, musst du auch, wenn du Teppich legst.
Ja, musst du auch sonst auch.
Ja, aber da funktioniert es wenigstens.
Wenn die Fasern dann den Staub aber auch festhalten, dann ist er halt auch nicht direkt an dir dran.
Während du auf so einem Steinboden alles einsammelst, was da rumliegt. Also ganz ehrlich.
Aber ich muss echt sagen, ich würde mich weder auf einen Steinboden noch auf
einen Messeteppich setzen, der da seit zwei Jahrzehnten durchgefurzt wird.
Der ist ja nicht seit zwei Jahrzehnten. Der ist ja neu. Der ist ja erst seit zwei Jahren da.
Der ist aber, also ja, ich weiß. Also okay, gut, Teppich.
Von mir aus ist es wärmer an den Füßen, aber es gibt schon auch einen Grund,
warum man sich irgendwie an den Stellen, wo es ein bisschen um Hygiene geht, keinen Teppich legt.
Man kann Teppiche heutzutage professionell problemlos in place reinigen.
Das ist ein gelöstes Problem.
Da gehst du mit dem Apparat rüber, der schäumt da einmal durch,
dann ist das korrekt sauber.
Sauber genug für Leute, die sich da mal draufsetzen. Du sollst ja nicht ablecken.
Ja, okay. Also ja, kann sein. Aber der... Teppich. Kneipe mit Teppich.
Kannst du nicht machen. In Berlin gibt es sogar Kneipen mit Sandboden.
Kennst du? Winterfeldplatz, Slumberland und so.
Ne, kenne ich.
Da wird dann jeden Abend gesiebt und nicht gesaugt.
Echt?
Ja.
Das nenne ich die ganzen...
Gibt es schon seit den 80er Jahren irgendwie den Laden. Was ich aber jetzt gerade
wegen Corona dicht gemacht habe, habe ich jetzt nicht verfolgt.
Das gibt es. Du kommst rein bis am Strand.
Nein, es ist ja in Ordnung, den Teppich zu haben. Ich wollte nur meinen generellen,
Teppich jetzt nicht so geil. Es ist okay, dass sie den Teppich haben und das ist auch schön.
Ich finde den teilweise vom Muster her ein bisschen, ist auch egal,
ist gut, die haben Teppich, finde ich super.
Ist okay.
Bevor es jetzt heißt, ich würde die Location bashen, weil sie Teppich hat,
ist in Ordnung. Saal 1 hat er auch Teppich.
Weiß ich gar nicht. Da, wo man geht, ist glaube ich kein Teppich mehr.
Doch, glaube auch. Das ist alles sehr plüschig auf jeden Fall.
Ich mag das. Das ist sehr fluffig auch. Gemütlich, angenehm und gute Akustik dadurch auch.
Akustisch ist das natürlich ein Zugewinn.
Jaja, es ist alles nicht so hallig und man merkt das, der hintere Bereich,
also dieses CCH, wer da noch nicht war, ist so im Wesentlichen in so drei Teile geteilt.
Die ersten beiden Teile sind sozusagen die klassischen alten ursprünglichen,
als das Ding in 60er Jahren oder so gebaut wurde.
Und dann kam irgendwann so, ich glaube in den 90ern, ein Anbau,
so ein Erweiterungsbau.
Da war dann halt alles so modern, wie man das damals gemacht hat.
Da hast du halt dein Parket hohe Decken und irgendwie alles weiß und irgendwie
ganz anders vom ganzen Fühl her.
Und ich fühle mich da sofort unwohler als in diesem vorderen Teil.
Also ich hätte es gerne gesehen, wenn sie den hinteren Teil sozusagen auch auf
denselben Gestaltungsstandard gebracht haben, aber das wollten sie nicht anfassen,
weil das musste nicht wirklich saniert werden, sondern hatten ja genug zu tun
mit dem vorderen Bereich. Und ich finde den Umbau extrem gelungen.
Also es ist einfach schön geworden. Dieses Atrium ist toll.
Ich finde es super, dass sie den Teppich beibehalten haben.
Die ganze Raumaufteilung ist viel, viel, viel sinnvoller und vor allem hat sie
dem Kongress voll in die Hände gespielt.
Es ist einfach genau das hinzugefügt worden, was der Kongress dringend gebraucht
hat, nämlich Platz für Hands-on-Areas, für Leute, die da einfach rumhacken und
Sachen zeigen, Community-Projekte etc.
Da gab es halt vorher nicht genug oder genug gibt es wahrscheinlich eh nie.
Aber eben flexibel nutzbare Flächen, so Multifunktionsflächen und trotzdem noch
die schönen alten Säle neu gemacht, die auch toll aussahen und einfach dieses ganze,
intensive Konferenzfeeling, was der Kongress immer hatte, einfach nochmal stark unterstrichen haben.
Da war also sehr viel mehr Interaktion zwischen Bühne und Zuschauern als man
das jetzt zuletzt in Leipzig gesehen hat und das war gut, dass dass das so war.
Ich hatte vor allem, also eine Sache, die sich auch in meiner Wahrnehmung geändert
hat, gegenüber, in Leipzig war es immer so, eigentlich waren die Vortragsseele häufig nicht voll.
Was wahrscheinlich eine unterschiedliche Gründe hatte. Also ich meine,
Saal 1 in Leipzig waren glaube ich so fünfeinhalb.
Das heißt, du musst auch erstmal fünfeinhalbtausend Leute interessieren.
Außer wieder reinkriegen.
Ja und auch, die müssen auch Interesse an deinem Talk haben.
Das musst du erstmal hinkriegen.
Und das Interesse muss so groß sein, dass es keine anderen, gerade ebenfalls
interessanten Dinge für die Leute gibt und, dass sie sich auf den Weg machen.
Ja, die Wege sind weit gewesen.
Was tatsächlich in Leipzig halt ein Thema war, da mussten längere Pausen zwischen
den Talks sein, damit du überhaupt schaffen kannst, von Saal Hassel nicht gesehen
in Saal Hassel nicht gesehen zu laufen oder mit deinem Roller zu fahren.
Und das hat dann häufig offenbar einfach, also ist natürlich klar,
wenn du sagst, okay, ich muss einen halben Kilometer zu diesem Talk laufen und
dann begegnest du jemandem, redest fünf Minuten, dann schaffst du es halt auch schon nicht mehr.
Und jetzt, lange Rede kurzer Sinn, in Hamburg auch sehr viel weniger Sitzplätze.
Also knapp 3000 hat der Saal 1.
Saal G und Z sind so im Bereich 1000. Der eine glaube ich 1001,
der andere 1100 oder sowas.
So ein Saal kriegst du natürlich auch mit, was weiß ich, 14.000 Besucherinnen
dann auch wirklich schneller mal voll und das hat aber natürlich dann auch den
Effekt, dass die Leute einmal checken, oh,
hier gibt's hier kann das passieren, dass ein Saal voll ist also muss ich da
jetzt auch mal hin und das insgesamt hat dann dazu geführt, dass insgesamt die
Seele auch, oder war so meine Wahrnehmung insgesamt die Seele regelmäßig voller sind.
Ich habe überhaupt nichts leer angetroffen.
Also ich war jetzt nicht in sehr vielen Vorträgen, aber überall,
wo ich war, war es immer voll.
Ja, genau das meine ich. Ist ja gut. Ist ja sehr schön.
Ist super.
Sehr, sehr schön.
Klar, jetzt aus einer Kapazitätsfrage könntest du auch sagen,
okay, heißt das, dass von den 14.000 Besucherinnen können immer nur fünf gucken,
das heißt neun dürfen gerade nicht in den Vortrag oder sowas.
Vielleicht ist es dann auch zu wenig, aber dafür gibt es dann aber wiederum genug andere Dinge.
Also insgesamt habe ich mich gefreut, dass das Programm gefühlt wieder eine
zentralere Rolle bei der Veranstaltung hatte, als es in Leipzig jetzt mit den
riesigen Assembly-Flächen und so der Fall war.
Es ist auch nicht so ein großes Problem mehr mit vollen Sälen,
weil wenn du jetzt wirklich auf der Veranstaltung in Echtzeit der Veranstaltung
folgen möchtest und da nicht reingekommen bist oder bist gerade zu weit weg,
Dann kannst du einfach dein Telefon zücken,
AirPods irgendwie in die Ohren klemmen, Stream anmachen und kannst in dem Moment
noch auf dem Weg dorthin verfolgen oder dich halt irgendwo in eine Ecke setzen
und dann einfach so zur Kenntnis nehmen. Das funktioniert auch ganz wunderbar.
Klar ist immer nochmal ein bisschen was anderes, gerade wenn man Fragen stellen
möchte oder so, aber das tut ja dann ohnehin nur so eine Minderheit oder kann
auch nur eine Minderheit tun, weil einfach der Zeitrahmen dafür gar nicht da ist.
Also ich glaube, dass das an sich überhaupt gar kein Problem ist,
dass das alles genau richtig dimensioniert ist und es ist genug Publikum,
um auch den Vortragenden das Gefühl zu geben, dass da Interesse besteht, definitiv.
Und vor allem dann auch genug Interaktion dort aufkommt und Reaktion auf das, was man sagt.
Es war immer gute Stimmung und es war einfach, ja, man merkte einfach,
wie alle auch so dem Content intensiv folgen und das verstehen oder Witze mitkriegen und all das.
Wenn ich mal was meckern darf, diese Fressbuden, die gehören irgendwo bestraft.
Also was ist da an diese Nahrungsmittelversorgung an Ort und Stelle?
Vielleicht kurzer Hintergrund, ohne das jetzt im Detail zu wissen, aber eine.
Location hat üblicherweise, wenn man so etwas baut, so eine Location,
dann hat die feste Rahmenverträge mit Catering-Anbietern.
Und die haben wiederum ein Abonnement darauf, bei jeder Veranstaltung dort catern zu dürfen.
Das heißt also, wenn wir als Club, die uns für die Location CCH entscheiden
und dort eine Veranstaltung mit so und so vielen tausend Leuten machen,
dann gibt es UnternehmerInnen, Organisationen, Firmen, die dann quasi den Rahmenvertrag haben,
dass sie da Nahrung anbieten. Und was die dann mit diesem Recht machen,
keine Ahnung, die vermieten das vielleicht dann unter an andere oder so,
aber wenn man sagen wollen würde, wir wollen euch da nicht, dann müsste die
Location eine Konventionalstrafe zahlen und der Club müsste die quasi dann,
die wird natürlich dann weitergereicht.
Also die kannst du nur rauskaufen, diese Leute. Mit anderen Worten, die wirst du nicht los.
So mal ganz kurz, ohne Details jetzt das Thema grob zusammenzufassen.
Das entbindet die aber nicht von der Pflicht, genießbare Nahrungsmittel dort
anzubieten, in einer akzeptablen Qualität, die den Preisen, die dort verlangt
werden, angemessen ist.
Und da rüge ich eigentlich alle Angebote, die ich dort gesehen habe,
mit dieser Pizza, das habe ich da mal versucht zu essen.
Dann gab es da noch diesen vegan-vegetarischen Asia, das war alles auf einem
Niveau, wo man nicht ein zweites Mal hingehen möchte. Und man ist aber vier Tage da.
Und das war, da sollte sich Hamburg nochmal was einfallen lassen.
Ja, also ja, ich fand jetzt die Pizza nicht ganz so schlimm,
aber das liegt ja auch mal ein bisschen im Auge.
Für den Preis war das eine Katastrophe, ne? Also die hat ja ihr Vermögen gekostet.
Ja, ja, du hast natürlich recht. Also das ist ein generelles Problem.
Ich weiß noch, wir hatten das am Anfang auch im BCC auch das Problem.
Irgendwann wurde dann allerdings dieser Vertrag mit dem Caterer auch gekündigt.
Gerade weil die immer wieder diese Erfahrung gemacht haben, dass die sozusagen
da nicht motiviert genug waren,
gerade so zwischen den Jahren, da halt sich auch so ein bisschen einzustellen
da drauf und das ist dann eben für die Veranstaltungslocation natürlich auch ein Problem,
weil ja dein Image auch so ein bisschen davon abhängt, wie das funktioniert.
Und gerade Essen ist immer schwierig, weil wenn die Leute beim Essen unzufrieden sind, gar nicht gut.
Und deswegen halte ich das generell eigentlich für einen Fehler,
das so an eine Firma so komplett zu delegieren und zu sagen,
ihr habt jetzt hier so einen Vertrag und keine Ahnung, wie das dann finanziell geregelt ist.
Aber man entledigt sich so ein bisschen der Verantwortung, das selber auch noch mit zu organisieren.
Aber grundsätzlich würde ich sagen, wäre es eigentlich sehr viel angemessener,
das Catering unter derselben Geschäftsführung zu haben, einfach um reagieren zu können.
Wenn die Kunden sagen, Leute, so wie das ist, passt es nicht zu uns,
können wir da nicht was anderes machen, so wie man sich ja auch sonst über alles andere auch unterhält.
Also vier Tage Pizza mit einem CCC kannst du es ja machen.
Also ein diverseres Angebot und ein umfangreicheres Angebot wäre sicherlich
gut gewesen. Der große Vorteil ist natürlich, wir sind da mitten in Hamburg
City und man konnte halt auch außerhalb.
Ich meine, die ist mal nicht da, aber üblicherweise profitiert ja einfach die
Schnellgastronomie des Bahnhofs Dammtor.
Ist eine der Primärprofiteurinnen des Kongress.
Also ich war dieses Mal nicht dort, aber ich glaube, dass die, ja die haben da.
Und ich glaube auch, dass das Hotel, was daneben an ist, Reddison,
dass deren Gastronomie sich auch gefreut hat, dass es da ein paar Leute gibt, die Nahrung brauchen.
Aber okay, Essen, gut, egal, man geht ja nicht zum Essen dahin.
Sondern trotzdem.
Ja genau, du gehst trotz des Essens dahin. Da sollte Hamburg uns schon dankbar sein.
Aber Internet war ganz gut auf der Veranstaltung.
Internet hat funktioniert, ja, aber das jetzt auch.
Da waren genug Datenelche anwesend.
Ja, das hat mich dann doch echt überrascht. Der Datenelch ist auf dieser Veranstaltung
zum Mem geworden. Und ich war...
Ich weiß nicht, also ich habe eine Idee, wie das passiert ist,
aber ich fand es vor allem tatsächlich lustig, weil es da echt eine ganze Reihe
an schönen Datenelch-Plakaten gab, über die sich auch viele gewundert haben
und dann uns verdächtigt haben.
Also wer noch nicht auf dem Chaos-Communication-Kongress war,
wir reden ja hier auch so ein bisschen jetzt in so eine Community rein und alle
anderen, die jetzt sozusagen aus
welchen Gründen auch immer für sich entschieden haben oder nicht haben,
anders entscheiden können und von daher sozusagen noch nicht am Kongress teilgenommen haben.
Schilder spielen so eine besondere Rolle auf dieser Veranstaltung.
Das ist so generell einfach so ein Medium, mit dem viel rumgespielt wird und
während der Kongress so voranschreitet, tauchen einfach immer wieder die weirdest,
Plakatideen, Hinweise, Sicherheitshinweise und sonstiger Schmuh auf und ja,
da verfestigt sich natürlich auch schnell das ein oder andere Meme und der Datenelch
war diesmal ganz weit vorne.
Vorne zum Beispiel so schlechter Empfang, nimm einen Datenelch mit und dann
so kleine Datenelche zum Abreißen, so wie man das normalerweise mit Telefonnummern
bei Wohnungsgesuchen macht.
Sehr schön fand ich auch das Datenelche aren't real, so nach dem Birds aren't real Ding.
Datenelch gesucht irgendwie 5G or Edge, also so viel wie Dead or Alive und so weiter.
I want to believe.
Daten. Sehr, sehr schön.
Das hat Spaß gemacht. Vermisst wurde auch einer.
Der vierbeinige Freund mit dem WLAN-Geweih ist aus seinem Lieblingswald in Brandenburg
abgedüst und mit ihm eine empfangstarke Aura, die jedes Signal aufpimpt.
Zuletzt erkennt es sein hochtechnologisches Geweih, das selbst den miesesten
Empfang auf Turbo schaltet. Sehr schön.
Kann jede WLAN-Party mit seiner bloßen Anwesenheit zum Erfolg führen.
Ein WLAN-Party finde ich auch gut. Ein LAN-Party war früher.
Naja, also toll, manche haben gerätselt und wussten überhaupt nicht,
wo das jetzt alles so herkommt.
Wir haben natürlich auffällig geschmunzelt.
Und viele, genau, einige haben gerätselt, interessanterweise haben viele halt
auch tatsächlich auf die falsche Folge LNP vermutet, denn wie wir ja letztes
Mal schon geklärt haben, oder ne, hab ich das hier schon?
Der Ursprung ist sehr viel früher als viele dachten.
Weil wir die Dateneche vor vielen Jahren hier schon mal erwähnt haben.
Als wir nämlich über skandinavische Netzluftbrücken, irgendwie Kehrpakete mit
Internet aus Skandinavien philosophiert haben. Die Originalfolge verlinken wir nochmal.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Nummer das war.
Da ging es um Klesen-Görne.
Genau, da haben wir dann irgendwie und Tim hat gesagt, die sollen Datenelche
rüberschicken und dann daraus hat sich das dann irgendwie,
weiterentwickelt Ich habe in die Sendung auch nochmal,
reingehört Ich habe die auch nochmal transkribiert Das war LNP 261 mit dem schönen
treffenden Namen Elchtest für die Bundesregierung,
Okay und genau dann haben die Hörerinnen angefangen Datenelche zu malen,
dann gab es die Folge darauf, war dann nämlich die,
Alkes Datae, wo dann auch die Gattung dieser Tiere nochmal direkt lateinisch
sich wieder gespiegelt hat und so weiter und so fort.
Also LLP 261, da haben wir den Datenelch geboren und dann jetzt sind wir da angekommen.
Ihr könnt übrigens auch immer noch schöne Datenelch-T-Shirts bei uns kaufen.
Wir haben die alle im Angebot.
Zwischenzeitlich war die eine oder andere Größe mal nicht verfügbar.
Das passiert immer so mehr oder weniger automatisch, wie da gerade so die Lagerbestände sind.
Also wenn ihr da irgendeine Größe nicht findet, dann ist es immer nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Und es wurden auch leider nicht alle vor weihnachten ausgeliefert
glaube ich die da so bestellt wurden ich habe jetzt auf dem kongress nicht viele
gesehen also eigentlich kein aber das sollte mittlerweile glaube ich proben
sein wenn wir auf jeden fall schon begeisterte zuschriften online bekommen wo
leute sich gefreut haben über das motiv ich finde es auch wirklich sehr sexy.
Okay, dann können wir noch mal ein bisschen über Vorträge beim Kongress sprechen.
Und wir haben festgestellt, dass wir, ich denke, die inhaltlichen Empfehlungen
zu den netzpolitischen Themengebieten, die werden wir eher über das Jahr zu
den verschiedenen Themen dann bringen.
Also weil natürlich, es gibt ja den Track Politics, Ethics and Society.
Und in dem natürlich sehr viele Vorträge, sei es jetzt zu Chatkontrolle,
zu Staatstrujanern und sonstigen Vorkommen,
den zu konsumieren wir natürlich nahelegen, wie wir es aber auch bei allen anderen
Vorträgen und Tracks des Kongress machen.
Machen und sprechen heute erstmal so ein bisschen über vielleicht gar nicht
unbedingt im Bereich der Politik notwendigerweise angesiedelte Highlight-Talks,
die vielleicht auch geeignet sind für Leute, die nicht da waren,
einen Eindruck von der Veranstaltung zu gewinnen oder für Leute, die da waren,
einen Eindruck davon zu gewinnen, was sie vielleicht verpasst haben, oder?
Ja.
Open and Closing hat dir gefallen, Tim.
Ja, genau, damit fing es schon mal an. Das ist ja ein Thema,
was mir auch sehr am Herzen liegt, weil ich über eine bestimmte Zeit ja dieses
Opening eigentlich immer übernommen habe.
Ich glaube seit dem 16C3 bis zum,
21C3, genau, da habe ich das Opening immer gemacht, aus der Motivation heraus,
daraus den Kongress sozusagen aus einer organisatorischen Perspektive näher zu bringen.
Also es war sozusagen auch so eine Phase des graduellen Fortschritts.
Es wurden immer mehr Dinge eingeführt.
In diesem Bereich ist so viel passiert.
Dann gab es auf einmal Programmplanung. Das war beim 21C3 mal was Neues.
Und solche Sachen, Systeme, Videoaufzeichnungen, All diese ganzen Maßnahmen,
auch Änderungen, die man so kommunizieren musste mit der Zeit,
dass man nicht mehr rauchen darf und so.
Das hat in der Phase ganz gut funktioniert und da habe ich halt auch gemerkt,
wie wichtig das ist, so eine gute Eröffnung zu machen, die auch wirklich so
ein Onboarding ist und die jetzt nicht nur in so einer Regelverlesung besteht, sondern wo man ja,
Leuten ein gutes Gefühl gibt und so ein bisschen was auch das Gemeinsame,
beschwört und vielleicht auch einsteigern, da eine Möglichkeit bietet,
schnell Anschluss zu finden und zu spüren, worum es bei der Veranstaltung eigentlich so geht.
Naja, und das ist, sagen wir mal, in den letzten Jahren mal so,
mal so gelaufen, verschiedenste Ansätze und Konzepte ausprobiert worden,
manches hat gut funktioniert, manches hat nicht so gut funktioniert.
Ich fand es dieses Jahr sehr gelungen, Bupe, Katascha und Mulana, genau,
die haben das da so im Konzert auf der Bühne gemacht und ich fand das sehr angenehm,
weil sie sich gut abgestimmt haben,
weil es gut vorbereitet war und weil sie vor allem auch klar Leute angesprochen haben,
die das erste Mal auf dieser Veranstaltung sind oder sich generell noch so ein
bisschen an die Szene herantasten und die natürlich dann an so einer Eröffnungsveranstaltung
sehr viel größeres Interesse haben als so die alten Hasen,
die das alles schon irgendwie 10, 20 Mal erlebt haben und sich auch von so einer
Veranstaltung relativ wenig Neues versprechen. Weil, kennen Sie ja schon. schon.
Und ich glaube, es gab auch, haben die gefragt, wie groß der Erstbesucheranteil
ist? Ich weiß es jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr, es kann sein.
Haben da irgendwie was gemacht, aber das ist ja dann auch jetzt nicht ausgewertet worden.
Ja, es ist genau, es ist da nicht reflektiert worden. Also auf jeden Fall,
meine Wahrnehmung war, dass das schon relativ groß war.
Ja, und dann ist das ganz gut. Und das gilt dann auch fürs Closing,
was dann vom selben Team gemacht wurde.
Und dann ist das einfach so eine klammer und wenn man an beiden veranstaltungen
dann auch vielleicht teilgenommen hat dann denke ich mal ist das ist das etwas
womit man dieses ganze event dann schön eingebettet bekommt und im idealfall
natürlich auch in guter erinnerung behalten kann das war ich gut.
Ja, also vor allem, weil eine solche Veranstaltung angemessen zu eröffnen,
ist eine Herausforderung.
Das geht auch gerne mal schief.
Und ja, dieses Jahr hatten wir halt mal das Glück, dass wir da eine angemessene
Eröffnung gefunden haben.
Ich würde den, also Frag den Staat hat natürlich mal wieder einen Wahnsinnsvortrag
hingelegt, Arne Semsrott, den sollten wir eigentlich eh auch öfter bei uns in
der Sendung haben, wir laden den viel zu selten ein,
das machen wir mal nehmen wir uns mal als guten Vorsatz für das Jahr hat natürlich,
also es ist einfach irre, was die die durchziehen in einem Jahr und wie unglaublich witzig das ist.
Und dann am Ende wird noch gesungen. Den Track kanntet ihr ja wahrscheinlich schon.
Und diesmal waren es ja vier Jahre, die sie zusammengefasst haben.
Genau, mussten vier Jahre zusammenfassen. Da waren natürlich viele spannende Sachen drin, aber ...
Ja, also das ist ohnehin ein ganz klares Must-See.
Aber eigentlich alle. Also ich frage den Startvorträge immer.
Kann man sehr empfehlen.
Kann man sehr empfehlen. Der fragt den Startvortrag, war der ursprünglich im
Fahrplan mal Tag 1, Saal 1? Also wäre der Eröffnungsvortrag gewesen.
Ist dann aber gewichen, weil das Zentrum für politische Schönheit auch da war
und aus unterschiedlichen Gründen,
man hat dann ja immer so ein bisschen Verfügbarkeitsprobleme,
hat dann Arne seinen Premium-Slot an das Zentrum für politische Schönheit abgegeben,
was eben nach dem Opening einen Vortrag gehalten hat.
Und die Inhalte, ich glaube, sind etwas andere als hier im Logbuch.
Insofern lohnt sich das auch für Leute, die die Folge gehört haben und Leute,
denen die Folge gefallen hat.
Was ich ganz besonders schön fand, war, dass sie ihren Vortrag mit einem Grußwort
von Alice Weidel, also da kam so ein Eröffnungsvideo und am Anfang sagt Alice,
also am Ende dieses Eröffnungsvideos sagt Alice Weidel so sinngemäß,
ja wir sind froh, dass wir diese Wursthaar-Veranstaltung von dem Chaos Computer
Club in unserem schönen Sachsen los sind.
Viel Spaß in Hamburg mit dem Gesindel, das ist schon einfach großartig.
Aber ja, ZPS-Vorträge eben auch,
knallen halt einfach rein und ein sehr großer Spaß wurde da natürlich auch ordentlich
abgefeiert und war ein großer Knüller eigentlich.
Du warst ja auch auf der Bühne, ne? Also hab ich mir auch angeschaut,
Hirnehacken, das ist ja mittlerweile eine Serie.
Ja, ja.
Habe ich so den Eindruck. Hast du zusammen mit Kai Biermann gemacht.
Zwei Psychologen im Tandem. Und habt nochmal schön diese Welt der Ransomware aufgegriffen.
Und sehr unterhaltsam. Da bist du ja quasi auf Publikumswünsche eingegangen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Der Wunsch dann doch mal genau zu schildern, wie denn so die die Kommunikation
zwischen Erpressern und Erpressten abläuft.
Das war dann doch schon sehr unterhaltsam, das alles zu sehen.
Ihr habt das dann so als stilisierten Chatverlauf dargestellt und dann aber
auch gerade Kai hat dann immer so schön auch Hintergründe geliefert,
was man denn so über die Leute weiß.
Das war ja so primär Russen in dem.
Zusammenhang, also so einzelne Individuen, die dann so auf Social Media sich
mit ihren dicken Autos dort zu Schaustellen oder vor ihren Pools und,
es kam dann so das ein oder andere Psychogramm dabei raus und es war dann auch
mal interessant zu sehen, wie wenig Leid diesen Leuten auch geschieht,
weil sie dort einfach nicht so richtig verfolgt werden,
es sei denn, sie machen mal so ganz große Fehler beziehungsweise wie es dann eben,
die trifft, die auf der untersten Linie dieser ganzen Organisation stehen,
also Leute, die für wenig Geld angeheuert werden.
Denn ja, es ist immer so und dort ist es halt auch so, an die dicken Fische
kommt man halt nicht so ohne weiteres ran.
Aber das war halt alles so belegt und recherchiert, was so in den letzten Jahren
jetzt wirklich gelaufen ist, fand ich sehr unterhaltsam.
Ja, du hast recht, es war auf Publikumswunsch, weil in dem Moment,
wenn ich mal irgendwo auch nur andeute, dass sich solche Verhandlungen,
mache, auch teilweise oder gezwungen bin, das manchmal zu tun,
interessieren sich die Leute da brennend für. Und das, also,
ja, und kann man den Erpresser nicht so, und kann man den nicht versuchen zurückzuerpressen
und alle möglichen Themen.
Und da nur so ein großes Interesse ist, ne?
Das ist so, das Geile finde ich, dass die Leute, wenn du sagst so,
hier, pass auf, da müsst ihr, so müsst ihr eure Systeme absichern,
also lame, Langeweilig, langweilig, hier mit Erpressern verhandelt.
Jo, ah, da, das würde mich aber jetzt mal interessieren.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, wenn ich über sowas spreche,
dann einmal und dann einmal beim Kongress.
Und tatsächlich ist es auch so, ich meine, ich habe da, wie gesagt,
längere Zeit mit gehadert, ob ich da überhaupt drüber spreche.
Aber der Punkt ist, wenn man nicht drüber spricht, dann überlässt man das Feld halt solchen,
es gibt da Leute, die halt das anbieten, Die das irgendwie als eine besondere,
als wäre das jetzt irgendwie was, also natürlich willst du, dass das jemand Externes macht,
aber die sind dann irgendwie so, ja ich bin aber hier Cyberprofiler und ich
führe diese Verhandlungen mit euch und tun so, als wäre es irgendein Geheimnis
oder was man da irgendwie, wie diese Verhandlungen laufen.
Deswegen habe ich mir halt gedacht, okay, dann erkläre ich mal,
wie sowas abläuft und welche Möglichkeiten man da hat und wie da die andere
Seite aussieht, weil ich natürlich auch weiß, die Menschen,
die dann in der Situation sind, dass sie eine solche Verhandlung führen möchten.
Die haben natürlich auch allerlei wirre Vorstellungen davon oder müssen oder
wie auch immer. Kann man sich gerne mal anschauen.
Ich hatte auf jeden Fall Spaß auch dabei, dass Kai dabei war.
Muss man halt sagen, Kai hat wirklich seit Jahren recherchiert über diese Gangs
und hat halt auch einige von diesen Leuten halt getroffen.
Und auch, was er in dem Vortrag gar nicht so hervorgebracht hat,
einige dieser Leute hat er auch selber entdeckt.
Also die hat er selber herausrecherchiert durch irgendwelche Doppelverwendungen
von Passwörtern oder E-Mail-Adressen und so.
Und war da streckenweise, einmal hatte er so eine Situation,
dass er sich bei jemandem total sicher war,
aber dann hat das FBI den nicht auf die Most Wanted Liste geschickt und hat
er seine Recherche nicht veröffentlicht und sechs Monate später hat der FBI
gedacht, ah, hier haben wir noch einen.
Also ja, der ist da auf jeden Fall sehr hinten dran und wir sind da drauf gekommen,
wegen unserem Vortrag beim Camp.
Hinten dran oder hinterher?
Hinterher, hinterher.
Das will ich doch machen.
Vorne weg eigentlich. Genau, den ich mit Matthias und Dominik gehalten hatte,
den Incident Disclosure und Hackback oder sowas. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Incident Disclosure und Hackback.
Wie hieß der denn? Werde ich auch nochmal verlinken. Wo wir nämlich so eine
Ransomware-Gang, da wir tatsächlich einen von deren C2-Servern und so aufgemacht haben.
Und das war auch mal ganz nicht uninteressant, wo wir ja eine Zeit lang einfach diese ganzen,
frisch von diesen Typen gebreachten Organisationen einfach sofort angeschrieben
haben und gesagt haben, Achtung, ihr habt hier ein Problem, Achtung,
ihr seid infiltriert worden und so.
Der Vortrag ist auch in dieser Reihe, den kann ich also auch empfehlen.
Und außerdem noch den Vortrag zu Busting Black Buster, ein weiterer Kollege
von mir, Tobias Müller, der nämlich für Black Buster einen Decryptor geschrieben hat.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt also wirklich so eine Reihe aus, wie verhandelt man
mit denen, wie hackt man die, wie warnt man die Opfer, wie entschlüsselt man
die Dateien ohne zu bezahlen.
Da ist glaube ich eine ganz, ganz nette Reihe.
Wie hieß denn dieser Vortrag richtig?
Unlocked Recovering Files, Taken Hostage by Ransomware.
Genau, das war natürlich sehr schön mit dem Motto zu spielen an der Stelle.
Das haben ja so einige getan.
Ja, das hat übrigens auch sehr schön funktioniert dieses Jahr. Das Motto und,
die grafische Umsetzung.
Schweigen, findest du nicht?
Doch, doch, doch. Das ist ganz wahr, was du sagst.
Das hat Louis und Josch gemacht.
Kann man auch an dieser Stelle nochmal loben für den für dieses schöne Design, schöne Merch.
Ja, vor allem ein interessanter grafischer Spin da sozusagen auf so ein ja,
ein bisschen Retro Pointillismus,
zurückzugehen und das Dithering auf einmal so als grafisches Element,
so als Barebones grafisches Element wieder zu entdecken.
Ich denke, das ist so für alle, die es so mit dem Minimalismus halt auch eine
schöne Stilvorlage gewesen. Das wäre ja auf jeden Fall gemessen.
Ja, das hat tatsächlich super funktioniert.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, also ich war dann, also Louis ist ein Freund von
mir und ich war natürlich ohnehin beim Design, bin ich ja in der Regel ein bisschen involviert.
Und als die so anfingen und meinten, ja hier Dithering und so,
da war ich erstmal so, oh, mal gucken, ob das jetzt irgendwie der Gewinn ist,
ob das der Hauptgewinn ist, einer,
gestalterischen Annäherung, aber die Umsetzung hat dann natürlich sehr viel für sich gesprochen.
So, next. Ich habe leider den Submarine-Talk verpasst.
Was? Bist du verrückt? Ja. Also das ist einer der besten Talks auf der ganzen Veranstaltung.
Das, ja, das kann sein.
Also das ist ein Vortrag, den wir schon seit längerem da haben wollten.
Also die Jungs haben, unsere Veranstaltung ist halt immer ausgefallen,
Aber die haben sich tatsächlich, also ein Vortrag, ja, ein Vortrag,
wie du ihn nur beim Kongress hast,
in einer Qualität, in einer Freude, mit einem Hacker-Spirit vorgetragen,
sucht wirklich einfach seinesgleichens.
Die haben sich irgendwo so einen Propangastank organisiert und haben gesagt,
wir bauen jetzt ein U-Boot.
Und in dem Talk wird mal nebenbei erklärt, wie so ein U-Boot funktioniert und
wie sie ihr es dann gebaut haben, welche technischen Herausforderungen sie hatten
und Sicherheitsvorkehrungen und so weiter.
Und das muss man natürlich sagen, so selbstgebaute U-Boote haben jetzt aktuell,
die haben nicht den besten Ruf.
Also nach diesem, muss man einfach mal sagen.
Die haben wirklich eine PR-Krise.
Nachdem diese eine Dose mit den Milliardären da drin auf dem Weg zur Titanic
geplatzt ist, oder die ist ja nicht geplatzt, sondern implodiert.
Und dann gibt es diesen skandinavischen Typen, der da eine Journalistin in sein
U-Boot mitgenommen hat und das auch ein sehr, sehr schockierendes Ende hatte.
Also wie gesagt, selbstgebaute U-Boote hier in der PR-Offensive mit einem herausragenden
Vortrag, kann man nicht anders sagen. Supergeil.
Den DRM-Talk, DRM in polnischen Zügen, den hatten wir ja schon,
also hatte ich glaube ich in der letzten Sendung schon angekündigt,
auch hier herausragend einfach, also in der Kombination,
genau das meine ich nämlich.
Nämlich diese Mischung, also technisch exzellente Vorträge erwartest du beim
Kongress, weil deswegen wurden sie da angenommen.
Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass sie auch noch in der Form des Vortrages und
der gesellschaftlich-politischen Gesamteinordnung herausragend sind.
Aber das ist natürlich bei Zügen jetzt naheliegend, weil der so viele Implikationen hat.
Also großartig vorgetragen von den Jungs,
die da irgendwie mit wenig Zeit und so für dann auch noch gerichtsfest diese
Manipulation nachweisen mussten und alle Arbeit gemacht haben und das einfach
herausragend, auch einfach herausragend kann man nicht anders sagen.
Ja, also das war einfach in bester HK-Tradition. Also die Art und Weise,
wie sie es vorgestellt haben,
wie sie auch ihr Material aufbereitet haben, wie sie Schritt für Schritt den
Vorgang sowohl in den technischen Details als auch in seinen eigentlichen Abläufen
in der Auseinandersetzung mit den einzelnen Unternehmen dargestellt haben.
Und dann auch so dieses Selbstbewusstsein, was sie dort zur Schau getragen haben,
ohne jetzt überheblich zu sein, aber so dieses so, ja die Bude versucht uns
jetzt gerade hier alles mögliche zu unterstellen, unter anderem haben sie das
hier behauptet, stimmt aber nicht,
weil das und dann haben sie das behauptet, stimmt aber nicht wegen das.
Also gleich so alle Argumente dann auch gleich noch mit widerlegt und das war
dann halt wirklich so Neo in der Matrix, ja komm schon irgendwie,
wenn ihr was wollt, ihr werdet sowieso verlieren. Also das war wirklich großartig.
Spitze. Also das ist wirklich so, deswegen geht man zum Kongress.
Das ist wirklich so der Content, den man da auf jeden Fall sehen möchte.
Ebenfalls ein Volltreffer war dann Operation Triangulation,
ein Talk der russische Vortragende von Kaspersky,
Wo du natürlich auch bei dem Annehmen des Talks denkst, können die überhaupt kommen?
Kriegen wir jetzt vielleicht auch Probleme damit, dass wir russische Vortragende haben?
Also alle möglichen Dinge. Also das sind natürlich Gedanken,
die wir uns irgendwie kurz bei dem Kontext auch gemacht haben.
Dann natürlich auch, okay, jetzt sind die von Kaspersky, auch irgendwie eine Frage,
ob die dann da jetzt stark, weil Kaspersky ja in Deutschland jetzt kein unumstrittenes
Unternehmen ist, aber auch auf technischer Ebene eine Wahnsinnsarbeit.
Die haben halt da die Arbeit, nehmen wir den Kaspersky Labs und stellen irgendwie
wirklich durch marginal,
dass sie es überhaupt gemerkt haben, weil ihr Netzwerk halt lokal heavy überwacht
ist, stellen sie auf einmal fest, dass ihre iPhones komische DNS-Requests machen.
Ja, was jetzt überhaupt schon mal, also die Art von Überwachung musst du erstmal
haben und da so genau reinschauen, dass dir so etwas auffällt.
Und dann erkennen sie halt so einen Footprint da drin und merken dann irgendwie,
okay, wir haben es hier mit einem Zero-Click-Angriff auf unsere Telefone zu tun.
Und reißen den halt komplett auf, inklusive der kompletten Schadsoftware aller Schwachstellen,
die da verwendet werden und melden die alle schön an Apple und reißen dann noch
komplett in diesen Schwachstellen halt noch etwas auf,
was in meiner Wahrnehmung schon ein bisschen aussieht wie eine absichtliche Backdoor.
Schwer zu erklären, warum man so etwas bauen würde.
Also, ja, und damit haben sie einfach mal einen kompletten neuen APT offengelegt,
also ein Advanced Persistent Threat, also eine,
Schadsoftware-Familie, End-to-End,
die natürlich jetzt die Russen der NSA zuweisen und die NSA dem FSB.
Also ich glaube, da ist noch nicht alles zugesagt,
aber schon eine krasse Veröffentlichung auch da im Bereich der Staatstrojaner
und der Angriffe auf Apple-Geräte.
Erklär nochmal kurz, was Zero-Click bedeutet in dem Zusammenhang.
Zero-Click bedeutet, dass du noch nicht einmal Nutzerinteraktion brauchst,
um ein Gerät zu kompromittieren.
Das ist natürlich relativ selten der Fall.
Also wenn du jetzt so ein Gerät dir anschaust, so ein iPhone oder auch ein Android-Telefon,
die meisten Angriffe würden jetzt erstmal davon ausgehen oder du brauchst quasi
eine, du hast ja relativ wenig Angriffsfläche im Sinne von was macht dieses Telefon,
ohne dass der Nutzer oder die Nutzerin überhaupt irgendetwas gemacht hat. Ja, also im Sinne von.
Deine Schwachstelle muss quasi durchmarschieren bis zu Root,
ohne dass du irgendeine Abhängigkeit davon hast, dass irgendwas installiert
ist, dass irgendwo ein Fehler gemacht wird oder sonstiges.
Also im Prinzip so eine Nachricht empfangen und schon alles ist vorbei.
Genau, eine Nachricht, Empfang, alles ist vorbei. Und in dem Fall haben wir,
und häufig hast du natürlich da dann,
also es ist meistens in diesen Killchains dann der Empfang einer Nachricht,
die irgendwie so ein Image-Parser auseinanderreißt,
weil das halt unglaublich komplex ist, unglaublich viele Dateiformate,
die irgendwie wirr sind und dann kann es, da ist üblicherweise viel Musik drin.
Also da steckt so ein PNG und das PNG ist aber nicht so wie die anderen PNGs,
sondern das nutzt so ein undokumentiertes oder nicht so gut dokumentiertes oder
oft nicht so richtig gut implementiertes Feature aus,
was zwar in den Spezifikationen steht, aber was kaum einer benutzt.
Und wenn das dann drin ist, dann ist der Code halt nicht so gut getestet und.
Dann macht er irgendwie was anderes und dann liest er sich aus diesem Bild die
Daten irgendwie in zu großen Mengen, speichert das irgendwo hin und dann fängt
das alles an auseinander zu fallen.
So diese klassischen Ausnutzungen von eben solchen Sicherheitsgründen.
Genau, und da schlummert dann irgendeine uralte Open-Source-Image-Rendering-Library,
die hat sich seit Jahren keiner mehr angeschaut.
Und dann brauchst du aber jetzt bei so einem iPhone natürlich,
da bist du ja noch nicht fertig.
Da bist du jetzt erstmal nur in dem Kontext der Messaging-App in diesem Beispiel.
Und jetzt brauchst du aber, um deine dauerhafte Schadsoftware unterzubringen,
musst du dann noch eine Privilege-Escalation hinkriegen.
Und die ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Insbesondere auf Mobiltelefonen, weil die eben ein relativ ordentlich umgesetztes Code-Signing haben.
Also Privileged Escalation heißt, normalerweise schlägst du erstmal als normaler
Nutzer aus, aber du hast sozusagen keinen besonderen Zugriff,
sondern musst dann in irgendeiner Form in dem Moment,
wo du durch Zero-Click, also einfach nur durch das Ankommen aktiviert wurdest,
muss der dort aktivierte Code dann eben sich auch noch irgendwo durchfräsen,
um quasi zum Hauptschlüssel zu geraten.
Ja, du bist erstmal in dem Kontext dieser App gefangen, was natürlich auch aus
Sicherheitsarchitekturgründen sehr viel Sinn macht und damit eben erstmal weg
vom Betriebssystem und davon irgendwie Systemrecht oder überhaupt in eine andere
App reingreifen zu können.
Das ist schon alles ganz ordentlich gebaut und da haben sie jetzt auch noch
wirklich spannende Schwachstellen gefunden,
die ich jetzt hier unter Berücksichtigung von Logbuch-Netzpolitik statt Logbuch-Cyber
nicht erklären werde oder nicht im Detail besprechen werde und vor allem auch,
weil die Speaker das sehr viel besser können als ich.
Also atemberaubende Killchain, irre Veröffentlichung, auch ein Talk,
den man sich durchaus mal anschauen sollte.
Was haben wir noch gehabt? Dann gab es noch was über internen Umgang auf der Veranstaltung.
Ja, also auch mal vielleicht ganz interessant, weil wir es auch hier in Logbuch
Netzpolitik damals behandelt haben, die Schiedsstelle.
Wir haben ja bei CCC-Veranstaltungen immer mal wieder die Situation,
dass es darum geht, eine Person von der Veranstaltung auszuschließen.
Aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Und vor vielen Jahren,
ich glaube mal 2018 oder so, haben wir dafür, weil wir festgestellt haben,
okay, dafür brauchen wir jetzt irgendwie einen Prozess, haben wir diese Schiedsstelle gegründet.
Und die haben jetzt seit ihrer Gründung zum ersten Mal so über ihre Erfahrungen
gesprochen, was sie da machen, wie sie entscheiden, wie sie sich dem Fall nähern und wie eben nicht.
Und das war sicherlich auch nicht ein spannender Talk für Leute,
die sich damit auseinandersetzen. Weil das natürlich nicht trivial ist,
diese Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Also jemanden von einer Veranstaltung, die erstmal grundsätzlich der Öffentlichkeit
offen steht, auszuschließen.
Und wie machst du das? Und da sind wir, also bin ich relativ froh,
dass wir da jetzt endlich vernünftige Strukturen für haben und die haben sich da vorgestellt.
Und wir haben es hier damals auch, als wir die Schiedschilde gegründet haben,
sehr ausführlich habe ich darüber berichtet.
Deswegen würde ich das auch nochmal so ein bisschen als Follow-up da und auch, dass man mal sieht, ja,
weil, also wenn ich mal jetzt kurz einen etwas schnippischen Kommentar bringen
darf, weil natürlich sehr viele Menschen bestimmte Ansprüche mit dem Besuch
der Veranstaltung verbinden.
Und mit denen allen umzugehen und natürlich auch, sorry, dass es eine ganze
Menge Leute gibt, die bestimmte Verhaltensweisen meinen,
auf solchen Veranstaltungen zeigen zu müssen, die absolut unangemessen sind
und die also absolut nicht gehen.
Und die Strukturen, die sich darum kümmern, insbesondere eben das Awareness-Team
und die Schiedsstelle, haben da mal so einen Einblick in ihre Arbeit gezeigt.
Das ist sicherlich für Leute, die das interessiert, durchaus mal interessant.
Ich habe gerade mal geschaut, welches Logbuch das war.
Ich meine, naja, Hilfsangebote hieß das Kapitel, genau.
Das ist Logbuch Netzpolitik 276 mit dem schönen Titel Trippfolie.
Dort hast du sehr ausführlich über diesen Prozess berichtet.
Sehr ausführlich im Sinne von, wir haben uns 53 Minuten und 16 Sekunden lang damit beschäftigt.
Fast so lang wie der Vortrag.
Genau, also kann man auch gerne nochmal dagegen halten.
Ich fand das sehr schön, weil du halt diese ganze sozusagen diese Hintergrundentwicklung,
was braucht man eigentlich, was ist eigentlich das Problem,
was können Ansätze sein, wie man sowas löst und wo gibt's da auch,
wo hat das auch das das Potenzial, dass man durch den Versuch einer Lösung neue Probleme schafft.
Das ist ja so eine ganze Kaskade und alles nicht so einfach.
Ja, und genau, also das war aber genau diese Folge da, das war quasi zur Gründung dieser Institution.
Und jetzt hier mal ein paar Jahre später, nachdem das eben Menschen gemacht
haben und da mal darüber sprechen, was sie da so erfahren und natürlich auch,
was sie streckenweise auch für Schwierigkeiten haben.
In der Ausübung dieser Tätigkeit.
Fünf Jahre später.
Dann gab es einen Vortrag oder eine Vortrags, ja was war das,
so eine Art Lightning Talk Serie unter dem Titel A New Hope.
Die hatte der Ruben Neugebauer primär angeleiert. Und das war ein faszinierendes Ding.
Niemand anders als Ruben Neugebauer hätte man sowas auch durchgehen lassen,
weil er wollte also eine ganze Reihe von Vortragenden aus unterschiedlichsten Hintergründen...
Kurz erklären lassen auf der Bühne, warum sie die Hoffnung nicht verloren haben.
Also die Anzahl an Vortragenden, ich weiß nicht, elf Leute oder so,
in 40 Minuten ist im Prinzip schon sowas, wo du sagst, nee, das lehnen wir ab.
Das funktioniert nicht, hier geht es doch nur jemandem darum,
mit möglichst vielen Einladungen Leute auf die Freitickets zu kriegen oder so. so.
Und ich fand das sehr, sehr gelungen.
Ich war einer davon, weil, und ich habe direkt gesagt, weil das so viele waren,
habe ich gesagt, nimm mich mal ans Ende, weil wenn die Zeit um ist und ich fall raus,
wegen Abschneiden, Zeit erreicht, dann ist es am wenigsten schlimm.
Aber ich bin sogar noch drangekommen, weil die alle.
Kurz zu fast waren. Genau, und da waren Dann, jetzt versuche ich hier gerade,
die Liste ist natürlich nicht auf Medias.
Doch, hier.
Ruben Neugebauer und Johannes Bayer haben das angeleiert. Dann war Carla Remzmer
da von Fridays for Future, Anne Semsrott, Lara Eckstein,
Thomas Lohninger, Helena Steinhaus, Pia Klemp, Ela,
Kirsten Rautenstrauch, Sebastian Jünemann, Tarek Alaufs und ich glaube da ist
noch die, hab ich jetzt Pia gar nicht genannt, doch Pia Klemp, genau.
Also es geht um Seenotrettung, Transparenz, sanktionsfrei,
Klimawandel, dann hier Sebastian mit Kados, die dann in Krisenregionen gehen,
Kampf gegen faschistische Tendenzen in der Gesellschaft, alles was schlechte
Laune macht und wurde immer so die Frage gestellt,
wie bewahrst du denn gute Laune?
Und ich fand es ganz interessant mal diese Menschen zu sehen und bei dieser
Gelegenheit auch kennenzulernen und fand das tatsächlich, dass das gelungen ist.
Ich fand das einen sehr schönen Überblick und auch mit sehr viel Liebe vorbereitet von Johannes und Ruben.
Das war eine Freude dabei zu sein und eine Ehre, da am Ende auch noch kurz was
sagen zu dürfen, während alle an großen Problemen arbeiten und jeden Tag wirklich Leid erfahren,
da auch nochmal kurz was sagen zu dürfen.
Was hast du gesagt? Du hast einfach nur gesagt, wenn es euch schlecht geht, hört Podcast.
Ich habe tatsächlich einen Tipp gegeben, wie man gute Laune behält.
Cliffhanger.
Wenn sie gute Laune behalten wollen, dann schalten sie ein.
Ja, war auch ganz cool gemacht. Einen Teil kann ich spoilern.
Am Anfang läuft Also A New Hope ist natürlich Bezug hier zu Star Wars.
Und da lief natürlich auch so ein Star Wars Text durch, der wirklich sehr gut war.
Und du kannst dir natürlich vorstellen, was der letzte Satz war.
Dieser Text wurde generiert von Chat-GPT.
Ich dachte, der steht nicht im Einklang mit der Policy.
Bei dir war wirklich gut. Und alle sitzen da, die Musik und lachen.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Kränkung.
Tja, gehört dazu.
So, nächster Talk. Was haben wir denn noch?
Ich rede die ganze Zeit. Ich warte immer, dass du mal einen vorstellst.
Naja, also ich habe gerade geschaut, dass das Prompt Battle,
kann das sein, dass das nicht aufgezeichnet wurde?
Ja, das Prompt Battle, naja, also Prompt Battle.
Ich fasse das Problem jetzt mal kurz so zusammen. Die haben das Flag gesetzt,
wird nicht aufgezeichnet.
Oder ne Moment also die haben zumindest den Leuten die da waren gesagt,
es wird nicht aufgezeichnet das war das Problem, genau, sorry ich hab grad falsch gesagt
und dann wurde es, weil sie das Fleck nicht gesetzt haben wurde es trotzdem
gestreamt und aufgezeichnet und jetzt warst du in dieser Situation dass sie
den Teilnehmerinnen gesagt haben das wird hier nicht aufgezeichnet,
und dann gesagt haben, war eigentlich ganz geil, könnte man doch mal veröffentlichen und jetzt,
die Teilnehmerinnen, die findest du nicht mehr mehr, weil die ja,
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, spontan da waren.
Und jetzt hast du halt Leute, die auf dieser Bühne waren, denen gesagt wurde,
das wird hier nicht aufgezeichnet und es wurde halt und jetzt hast du halt irgendwie
Schrödingers Aufzeichnungen,
wenn sie einfach nur gesagt hätten, zeichnet es ruhig auf und veröffentlicht
es, wäre alles gut gewesen, aber wenn du, oder wenn sie es auf,
ich glaube, so war das Problem.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt die Situation, warum es Okay,
also vielleicht gibt es die Aufzeichnung auch noch, sodass man nochmal das,
die Leute nochmal fragen könnte, ob das okay ist.
Naja, du müsstest halt die Leute, aber die Leute haben ja nicht ihre Adresse gesagt.
Ja, aber die waren glaube ich teilweise dann doch bekannt, also.
Genau, aber ich glaube, das war das war zumindest, ohne jetzt ins Detail zu
gehen, weil ich jetzt auch wieder auf Halbwissen,
agiere, das ist irgendwie das Problem mit diesem Talk, dass es irgendwie konträre
Anweisungen und Und Ansagen dazu gab, ob und wie der aufgezeichnet werden darf
oder nicht und hin und her.
Okay, es war ja auch kein Talk, sondern es war ja so eine klassische Entertainment-Nummer,
wie man sie auf dem Kongress ja auch oft findet.
Also so eine Art Spiel auf der Bühne.
Prompt Battle ist halt, kurz gesagt,
so Bilder erzeugen mit entsprechender AI-Software, in dem Fall Dolly 2.
2, die mit dem, was man jetzt schon so aktuell gewohnt ist aus unseren Episodenbildern,
zum Beispiel mit Dolly 3, schon gar nicht mehr zu vergleichen ist.
Aber das kann dann halt irgendwie lokal installiert werden und dann funktioniert
das auch relativ schnell und die Herausforderung ist einfach,
dass zwei Leute gleichzeitig,
versuchen in einem beschränkten Zeitraum von 60 Sekunden ein richtiges Prompt
zusammenzubauen, um die vorhergestellte Aufgabe,
was für ein Bild erzeugt werden soll, zu lösen und das ist ganz unterhaltsam
und dann gibt es halt so Ausscheidungsrunden und irgendwann ein Finale.
Ja, das war in der Tat sehr unterhaltsam und ich hätte jetzt gerne gesagt,
schaut euch das mal an, aber,
das ist dann sozusagen so ein Feature, nur die, die dabei waren, wissen, wie cool es war.
Also ich sag mal, meine persönliche,
Einstellung dazu ist, also es gibt einen weiteren Talk, der der ärgerlicherweise
nicht aufgezeichnet wurde. Und das ist der von Holger Stark, der...
Am ersten Tag zu einer besonderen Zeit über die Situation zu Julian Assange
gesprochen hat, was ja ein wichtiges Thema ist.
Und der aus verschiedenen Gründen da irgendwie halt Inhalte in diesem Talk hatte,
die er in der Form nicht veröffentlichen kann.
Und der dann eben auch vor der Frage natürlich war, ob er jetzt auf diese Inhalte
verzichtet oder auf die Reichweite und ich hätte mir natürlich gewünscht,
dass er eine andere Entscheidung getroffen hätte.
Insofern ist jetzt wieder einfach nur eine Linus-persönliche Meinung.
Ich finde, man sollte wirklich, eigentlich
gibt es wenig Gründe für das Do-Not-Publish sich zu entscheiden.
Weil, wenn du das eh vor ein paar tausend Leuten machst, dann ist es ja eh jetzt
nicht mehr geheim, egal was da passiert ist.
Finde das würde fast mal, ich glaube, ich werde mal in größerer Runde zur Debatte
stellen, ob man das überhaupt noch anbietet als Option.
Aber es gibt dann natürlich auch immer mal wieder was, wo du sagst,
ja okay, da muss man das vielleicht echt mal nicht machen und so.
Es gab auch hier mal vor Jahren den Talk von Moxie, da habe habe ich das dann,
das war mein Fehler, da habe ich einen großen, habe ich einen Fehler gemacht.
Moximalen Spike hatte einen Vortrag gehalten und den hatte ich,
das ist der Gründer von Signal, den hatte ich,
über direkten Kontakt irgendwie halt gepflegt und betreut und dann sagte er,
hat er irgendwie am Rande gesagt, er will nicht, dass es aufgezeichnet wird
und dann habe ich vergessen dieses Fleck zu setzen, was dazu führte,
dass er aufgezeichnet wurde.
Und dann Und dann war der halt öffentlich und dann war natürlich irgendwie,
war Moxie erstmal unhappy,
ja, und ich war natürlich, musste, hab mich dann entschuldigt und dann am Ende
war es aber so, dass Moxie dann auch sagt, ach komm ey, jetzt ist das Ding eh
so viele tausend Mal hier schon geguckt worden, jetzt kannst du auch online lassen, ist halt...
Scheiße gelaufen, aber egal.
Ist halt scheiße gelaufen, ja, aber ja.
Es gab auch, glaube ich, mal so Theater- Performances, die dann nicht aufgezeichnet wurden.
Ja, genau, die touren dann noch und wollen dann deshalb nicht aufgezeichnet
werden, weil sie ja, aber ich hab irgendwie, ach, ich weiß nicht,
ja, vielleicht sollte man, vielleicht, ich werde das mal in den entsprechenden Runden mal als Thema,
zur Diskussion fragen, ob das nochmal jemand diskutieren möchte.
Viel mehr kann ich ja nicht machen.
Glücklicherweise aufgezeichnet wurde der schöne Vortrag, How Many Planets Are
in Our Solar System, den ich jetzt hier mal so stellvertretend für den Science
Track, den wir noch gar nicht so richtig beleuchtet haben, nennen möchte, von Michael Büker,
der da sehr kundig ist in dem Umfeld und auch kundig berichtet hat und,
wie ich finde, eine schöne Perspektive gehabt hat.
Also, wie viele Planeten Unser Sonnensystem hat, das ist tatsächlich ein Moving
Target im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Das rangiert so von 6 bis irgendwie 200.
Und der Acker hat das sozusagen in seinem ganzen historischen Verlauf und warum
das dann jeweils so war, beziehungsweise welche Entdeckungen und wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnisse dann wieder dazu geführt haben,
dass man gesagt hat, so können wir das jetzt aber nicht sehen,
wir müssen das mal anders definieren.
Es gibt ja dann immer so viele Leute, die so Pluto nachtrauern als Planet.
Aber da gibt es natürlich auch schon sehr gute Gründe dafür,
warum Pluto nicht mehr als Planet geführt wird.
Und last time I checked, Pluto gibt es noch. Also ganz unabhängig davon,
wie wir den bezeichnen, ist schon noch da.
Das Lustige ist, es gab ja diese Mission New Horizons, diese super schnell losgeflogene
und reisende Sonde der NASA,
die dann ja diese großartigen neuen Bilder von Pluto überhaupt erst gemacht hat.
Wir haben ja seit wenigen Jahren wirklich mal ein Bild davon,
wie Pluto aussieht und es sieht total super awesome aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Bilder noch im Kopf hast, so mit diesem Herz auf der Oberfläche.
Und als die Mission gestartet ist, war sozusagen Pluto noch ein Planet und es ankam dann nicht mehr.
Ja, das war eine große Kränkung, Pluto diesen Planetenstatus abzuerkennen.
Für wen? Für Pluto?
Für Disney, für Pluto, für...
Ja, Kränkung. Ich meine, das heißt ja dann, das ist ja dann sozusagen,
das ist ja dann auch wieder so ein, wie soll man das nennen? So eine...
Für meinen Vater, der mir jeden Sonntag unsere neuen Planeten erklärt.
Für Leute, die sich keinen anderen Satz merken können. Oder nicht wissen,
in welcher Reihenfolge die Planeten wirklich so um die Sonne herum schwirren.
Nee, das ist, sagen wir mal, auch so eine Bevorzugung von Planeten.
Als ob Planeten jetzt irgendwas Besseres wären als Zwergplaneten.
Ja, man kann auch darüber stolz sein, ein Zwergplanet zu sein.
Das ist ja dann auch wieder so eine, wie nennt man denn das?
Ich komme jetzt gerade aufs Wort nicht. Ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall,
ich bin da Team transneptunische Objekte.
Auch in dieser Region gibt es viele schöne Größen. Unter anderem gibt es ja
auch noch den Zwergplaneten Eris.
Der tummelt sich ja da auch so bei Pluto rum.
Und die sind nicht minderwertig. Das sind auch gleichberechtigte Mitglieder
der planetaren Gesellschaft.
Aber sag mal. Oh, herrje. Boah, ich wollte gerade mal gucken,
welchen Ersatz die jetzt gefunden haben.
Für wen? Für Pluto?
Für mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unseren neuen Planeten.
Moderne Alternativen sind, mein Vater erklärt mir jeden Sonntag unsere Natur
oder unseren Nachthimmel.
Oh, das ist doch kein Ersatz. Gib dem Pluto den Status zurück.
Kannst du denn jetzt die acht Planeten in der richtigen Reihenfolge auch sagen?
Merkur, Venus, Erde, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn, Uranus, Neptun, Pluto.
Nein, kein Pluto. Das ist kein Planet.
Genug für euch dabei zum Einstieg?
Für die nächste Woche genug zum Klicken. Unter der Annahme, dass ihr einen Teil
davon gesehen habt und jetzt vielleicht noch zwei, drei Empfehlungen habt,
könnt ihr erstmal nochmal klicken.
Achso, mein Talk kann man gerne empfehlen und verbreiten, die anderen sind genug geguckt.
Achso, wollte den keiner sehen bisher, hast du noch keine Klicks?
Nee, der ist, der ist, ich darf nicht, ich werde mich hüten,
mich zu beschweren, aber der ist tatsächlich sehr spät, dann dann erst online gegangen.
Und dadurch hat er so ein Late Start.
Nicht genug Promo bekommen. Verstehe.
Nicht genug Promo bekommen, ja.
So, haben wir noch einen Aspekt zum 37C3?
Von mir aus können wir uns jetzt mal den anderen Themen widmen.
Gut.
Oder möchtest du noch, hast du noch was dazu? Ich habe es noch nicht ganz gehört,
ihr habt es in der Freakshow ja behandelt.
Was denn?
Die Veranstaltung 37C3 am Rande.
Ja. Ja, ausschließend.
Da ist mir nochmal auch aufgefallen, wie schön das ist, dass die Freakshow wieder lebt.
Ja, die war ja lange Zeit Corona geschädigt und so und man merkt jetzt,
ich weiß, dass ich es dir schon mal gesagt habe, ich weiß nicht,
ob ich es hier im Podcast schon mal gesagt habe.
Was gesagt habe?
Dass es schön ist, dass es schön ist, dass die wieder belebt wurde und auch
mit frischen Stimmen oder also Ralf Stockmann, der da jetzt zum Inventar inzwischen gehört,
der der Sendung auch einfach wirklich gut tut und,
ja, es ist schöne, schöne es ist jetzt eine fast komplett andere Besetzung, oder,
Max Rinder auf einmal Roddy war ja vorher dabei Max war jetzt zweimal dabei,
also derzeit haben wir so den den Modus, dass,
Roddy,
Ralf und ich so die Kernbesetzungen sind.
Das war mir ein Wunsch, dass die Sendung ein wenig mehr Kontinuität hat.
Also Kontinuität im Sinne davon, dass man eben, so wie wir das ja hier auch
machen, wir können ja jederzeit auch reflektieren mit, haben wir letzte Woche
schon besprochen, haben wir vor zwei Wochen besprochen, wir können sozusagen
jede Sendung im Kontext machen.
Und durch das etwas was angewachsene große Team, wo dann immer nur mal die,
mal die da waren, ist diese Kontinuität so ein bisschen verloren gegangen.
Und das ist so eine der Sachen, die mir wichtig waren, dass man da jetzt sozusagen
die Themen über einen längeren Zeitraum auch begleiten und immer wieder neu aufgreifen kann.
Das ist auf jeden Fall das Ding. Und was sich jetzt so im letzten Jahr eingebürgert
hat, dass wir jetzt eigentlich in jeder Sendung eine weitere Person quasi als Gast dabei haben.
Das hatten wir auch immer mal wieder, aber das ist jetzt schon fast,
ich will nicht sagen Tradition geworden,
das muss auch jetzt nicht unbedingt immer so bleiben, aber das ist jetzt gerade
so ein bisschen mein Ziel,
dass man quasi immer so eine Position hat mit einer anderen Person,
Die dann wieder neue Aspekte reinbringt und neue Themen und andere Anknüpfungspunkte
und andere Sichtweisen und so.
Das funktioniert soweit ganz gut, das finde ich passend.
Und wir haben natürlich auch über den Kongress gesprochen und verschiedenste Aspekte.
Natürlich. Und viel über AI und so.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass ich nicht genau weiß, ich musste die Freestyle auch neu abonnieren.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob die irgendwie wegen Untätigkeit irgendwie aus meinem
Podcatcher geflogen ist.
Eigentlich kann das nicht sein. Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Gibt es hier was. Also falls irgendjemand noch überrascht ist davon,
dass es die Freakshow wieder gibt, gibt es wieder.
Könnt ihr abonnieren und findet ihr Freakshow.
FM derzeit im Drei-Wochen-Rhythmus. Es ist schon meine Absicht,
das vielleicht mal wieder zu verkürzen. Früher waren wir ja so im Zwei-Wochen-Takt.
Ich wollte jetzt erstmal diese Kontinuität wieder haben Und die ließ sich jetzt
mit einem Drei-Wochen-Takt erstmal mehr sicherstellen. Dafür sind die Sendungen
dann sehr lang geworden.
Die letzte war fast fünf Stunden lang. Also da gibt es halt genug zum Hören.
Kann man im Prinzip jede Woche eine Stunde hören und dann ist man irgendwie auch gut bedient.
Ja Tim, vielleicht kommst du dann doch nochmal in so einen 9-to-5-Job.
Ich.
Acht Stunden Freakshow.
Ja, ich meine, so ein Podcast kann schon ganz schön lange dauern.
Also ich sitze da mittlerweile dran, jetzt muss man auch noch so viele Bilder generieren.
Jetzt wollte Ralf auch noch, dass ich Kapitelbilder mache. Gott.
Ja, finde ich aber auch eigentlich angemessen.
Ja, ist schön, aber es ist dann, das ist wirklich, also das ist Arbeit.
Hey, du Armer.
Naja, es ist dann weißt du, dann, also guck mal wenn wir jetzt mal hier kurz
beleuchten wir quatschen jetzt hier vielleicht so zwei Stunden on air,
also was dann irgendwie tatsächlich in die Sendung einfließt beziehungsweise
jetzt haben wir schon zwei Stunden
beisammen das wird heute bestimmt schon wieder ein bisschen länger so,
dann machen wir in der Regel mal locker je nachdem wie wir so drauf sind und
wie wir so vorbereitet sind und wie viel Nachhol.
Informationsnachholbedarf wir haben, so eine Stunde,
manchmal auch zwei Stunden vorher einfach so im,
im Warmen werden, so Vorbereitung.
So sind wir schon mal so irgendwo zwischen zwei und vier Stunden,
die man quasi jetzt so nur mit der Aufnahme beschäftigt ist.
Und dann muss das Ganze nochmal geschnitten werden, dann muss das alles nochmal
refined werden, muss das irgendwie beschrieben werden, Bilder gemacht werden und so weiter.
Kapitelmarken, alles richtig gesetzt, alles schön, nichts vergessen. ein bisschen Pipapo,
sitzt man da auch nochmal manchmal ein bisschen, es geht manchmal schneller,
es dauert manchmal ein bisschen länger, je nachdem, also man ist schon so einen
Tag mit so einer Sendung locker beschäftigt.
Bei einer 5-Stunden-Sendung wie mit Freakshow, ja, das frisst teilweise mal
zwei Tage, weil man sich ja auch vorbereitet und Themen sammelt,
auswählt, und dann trifft man sich irgendwie zwei Stunden vorher und dann geht
das irgendwie 5 Stunden und dann will man die Sendung noch fertig machen und
es ist eigentlich schon viel zu spät und dann ist man auch langsam und dann
macht man es am nächsten Tag und naja, dauert.
Anyway, aber ich klage ja nicht, das ist ja hier sozusagen das,
was ich auch gerne tue und ja, das könnt ihr dann alle mal reinhören.
Also wer jetzt von 37C3 noch nicht genug hat, da in der.
Freakshow 273 gibt es nochmal eine, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange wir darüber
geredet haben, eine halbe Stunde oder so, gibt es auch nochmal ein paar Talks
und ein paar Beleuchtungen verschiedenster Aspekte.
Alright. So, jetzt blicken wir mal nach Großbritannien.
Da ist mir nämlich eine Meldung untergekommen, die fand ich dann doch sehr bemerkenswert.
Eine Geschichte, die sich tatsächlich jetzt schon seit fast 25 Jahren abspielt.
Und zwar, wann ging das los hier in Deutschland, dass die Post so,
und nicht nur die Post, sondern alle Versender, Hermes und wie sie alle heißen, angefangen haben,
Reinigung und Schreibwarenläden und was sonst alles noch an Kleinstläden ist,
so zu Filialen zu machen?
Ähm, naja, haben die das gemacht? Ich meine, die haben ja eher,
also ich hätte das jetzt so verstanden, dass sie,
achso, nee, Moment, achso, okay, ich habe deinen Satz gerade nicht so 100% richtig verstanden.
Also die Versender, da hast du ja mal das Problem, du kriegst diese Pakete nicht
zugestellt und deswegen sind sie dann irgendwann auf die Idee gekommen,
ohnehin schon existierende Infrastrukturen von Läden in den Straßen,
die sich halt allen möglichen Themen gewidmet haben, eben wie gesagt von der
Reinigung bis zum Schreibwarenlernen quasi auch noch als Paketstationen zu machen
oder wie es bei der Post auch teilweise ist, sogar auch zu vollständigen Postfilialen.
Ja, jetzt ist es ja, also ich glaube Hermes hat ja nie etwas anderes gehabt
also Hermes hat ja angefangen damit, dass du deine Hermes-Pakete,
abgegeben hast in irgendeinem Spätkauf Reinigung, was weiß ich Friseur die,
dann da so ein Hermes,
Ding hatten, dann waren die halt ein Hermes-Paketshop. Also Hermes hat ja,
glaube ich, gar keine eigenen Services.
Nee, nee, genau, richtig.
Wann hat es damit angefangen? Also als Hermes angefangen hat,
hat es damit angefangen.
Ja gut, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht. War es Hermes? Kann sein, dass es Hermes war.
Aber es gab ja auch von vorher schon DHL, es gab vorher auch UPS.
Du konntest ja auch Pakete abholen, lassen, beziehungsweise bei der Post halt
in den normalen Postfilialen.
Aber irgendwann hat sich das sozusagen auf das gesamte, die gesamte wirtschaftliche
Infrastruktur, die halt überall ohnehin schon Standorte hat verteilt und dann
eben diesen Unternehmen die Möglichkeit gegeben,
an diesen Paketen auch noch mitzuverdienen und ob das dann ein Fair Share ist,
ist dann nochmal eine andere Sache, aber auf jeden Fall wurden sie sozusagen
Teil dieses gesamten Versendenetzwerks und so war das eben auch in Großbritannien,
und das Post Office,
also quasi das im Vergleich gleich zur Deutschen Post in Großbritannien,
hatte 1999 wohl schon so an die 11.500 Postfilialen,
die halt nicht wirklich dem Post Office gehörten, sondern die halt irgendwie
so selbstständige Unternehmer waren. Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt...
Wie das genau rechtlich organisiert war, aber sozusagen Leute,
die mehr oder weniger auf eigene Rechnung arbeiten und dann quasi unter anderem
auch eine Postfiliale sind.
So und damit das Ganze aber dann finanziell auch im Sinne des Post Office so abläuft,
hat das Post Office diesen Filialen, wir reden jetzt hier von einer Zahl von
ungefähr 11.500 Filialen, die das hier betraf zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
denen vorgeschrieben eine bestimmte Buchhaltungssoftware zu verwenden,
wo halt die ganzen Einnahmen, Ausgaben etc.
Alles, was mit dem Postversand verbunden war, dann vermerkt wird,
damit es dann eben nachvollziehbarerweise auch alles in einer ordnungsgemäßen
und einheitlichen Form beim eigentlichen Post Office dann auch verbucht werden
kann und die Abrechnung mit diesen Filialen gemacht werden kann.
Und dort haben sie dann auf eine Software des Fujitsu-Konzerns zurückgegriffen,
die also diesen ganzen Apparat dann ermöglichte.
Das Problem war jetzt, dass schon zu Beginn es immer wieder so ein paar Fälle gab,
wo die Software etwas unerklärliche Fehlbeträge auf einmal nachgewiesen hat,
die diese Filialisten angeblich nicht korrekt ausgeglichen haben.
So dass sich da über die Zeit Forderungen aufsummierten, die dann das Post Office
diesen Filialen in Rechnung gestellt hat.
Weil hier gucke mal, hier ist die Abrechnung, das passt ja irgendwie alles gar
nicht. Und das nahm so richtig Überhand und betraf auf einmal unheimlich viele.
Also es machte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob jetzt hier auf einmal so
ein Netzwerk, so ein Betrugsnetzwerk am Start ist, wo unter Ausnutzung eben
dieser Filialaktivitäten dem Post Office Geld entzogen wird.
Am Ende gipfelte das da drin, dass das Post Office über tausend Filialen verklagt hat von denen.
Ungefähr 900 Personen dann sogar verurteilt wurden, weil sie hier in irgendeiner
Form Geld hinterzogen haben sollen und dann zur entsprechenden Ausgleichszahlung
auch verurteilt wurden.
Tja, das hatte dann entsprechend katastrophale Auswirkungen.
Es gab natürlich zahlreiche Pleiten, entsprechend zerstörte Existenzen,
gescheiterte Ehen und auch mindestens vier Selbstmorde, die darauf zurückzuführen waren.
Und das Ganze, obwohl schon 2009 erhebliche Zweifel daran aufkamen,
dass es denn hier mit rechten Dingen vorgeht und die Vermutung im Raum stand,
dass es hier sich unter Umständen dann doch vielleicht eher um einen Softwarefehler handelt.
Dass also diese ganzen Postfilialen sehr wohl korrekt abgerechnet haben,
nur diese Software dieses korrekte Abrechnen nicht entsprechend ausgewiesen hat.
Eine Zeitschrift Computer Weekly hat 2009 vor diesen Fehlern dann gewarnt.
Das hatte dann allerdings keinerlei politische Folgen.
Und dann wurde so eine Sammelklage gestartet der Betroffenen.
Das zog sich dann zehn Jahre und 2019 gab es dann tatsächlich ein entsprechendes
Urteil, wo halt festgehalten wurde,
dass das eben ja wohl alles nicht so rechtens war und das führte dann 2020 dazu,
dass dann eben das Parlament tatsächlich auch eine Untersuchungskommission eingesetzt
hat, um das eben dann mal zu untersuchen.
Zog sich also alles noch ein bisschen, betraf ja ein Staatsunternehmen.
Und da ist man dann mit der Verurteilung nicht so weit.
Das Ganze ist jetzt eine Meldung geworden, weil in der Zwischenzeit der Sender
ITV hier so eine vierteilige Fernsehserie daraus gemacht hat. Mr. Bates vs.
The Post Office und damit ist das sozusagen der Öffentlichkeit jetzt Anfang
dieses Jahres nochmal so richtig um die Ohren gehauen worden und dann hat es
eigentlich erst diesen Skandallevel erreicht, den es 2009 im Prinzip schon verdient gehabt hätte.
Und jetzt muss natürlich alles ganz schnell gehen.
Mittlerweile hat der Regie Sunak, der aktuelle Premierminister,
in Großbritannien 600.000 Pfund Entschädigung pro Person zugesagt von diesen
900 betroffenen Leuten etc.
Wie er die Selbstmorde ausgleichen will, glaube ich, hat er noch nicht gesagt.
Naja, warum erwähne ich das? Weil wir es natürlich jetzt hier wieder mit so
einer klassischen Geschichte zu tun haben mit,
Risiken durch Software. Und ich würde sagen 900 gescheiterte Existenzen oder
zumindest verurteilte Personen,
das ist dann schon mal so ein Risikopotenzial, da muss man sich halt schon nochmal
darüber Gedanken machen, wie man denn sowas auch rechtlich absichert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, inwiefern unsere Gesetze, dürfen unsere juristischen
Zuhörer mal wieder schon mal die Kommentartastatur hervorholen,
inwiefern es hier sozusagen automatische oder explizite Absicherungen gibt bei
solchen Projekten, um Leute vor Fehlern in Buchhaltung zu schützen.
Aber es ist natürlich klar, also umso mehr wir uns auf Software verlassen,
wird es eben in zunehmendem Maße schwierig, hier überhaupt noch nachzuweisen,
was denn nun eigentlich richtig ist.
Gut, bei einer Buchhaltung kann man im Prinzip schon auch irgendwie im Prinzip
nachrechnen. Also eine gute Buchhaltung sollte das zumindest können.
Wenn Tim das gemacht hätte, wäre es nicht passiert.
Ja gut, das Wesen der doppelten Buchhaltung ist ja, dass das eben alles nachrechenbar ist.
Das ist ja das Schöne an diesem Kontensystem.
Also man kann sowas schon auch überprüfen und das wurde ja hier letzten Endes auch getan.
Trotz alledem ist natürlich die komplexität von software
teilweise schwierig zu überprüfen und
wenn er halt irgendwie die software einfach nur in roten balken hinschmiert und
sagt hier fehlen 5000 euro dann sagst du ja auch
nicht wie das ein bug dann nimmst du natürlich auch erstmal so hin wenig konsequenzen
hatte die ganze geschichte mittlerweile für die leute die in charge waren es
gab da zwar den ein oder anderen rücktritt aber ich meine wenn die die anderen
alle so verurteilt werden und die davon Kenntnis hatten,
dass sie sozusagen auch Anhaltspunkte hatten, dass es ja auch so wirklich an
dieser Software liegt und die lagen halt schon seit 2009 vor,
denke ich mal, hätte schon in den zehn Jahren dann doch,
sehr viel mehr passieren müssen.
Mehr als zehn Jahre, 15 Jahre fast.
Das ist halt, denke ich, der, der, ja, Mann ey, das ist tatsächlich natürlich
ein Problem, wenn Software-Bugs Konsequenzen haben.
Und dummerweise können die halt am laufenden Band auftauchen, tun es auch.
Und dummerweise sind häufig die Konsequenzen halt nicht so schlimm.
Hier ist jetzt ein Beispiel von fürchterlichen Konsequenzen.
Und da stellt sich natürlich die Frage der Verantwortung und Verantwortlichkeit
stellt sich aber primär natürlich in, wer hat verhindert, dass das untersucht wurde?
Wer hat verhindert, dass es korrigiert wurde?
Also wo beginnt die Fahrlässigkeit, wo beginnt das wieder besseren Wissens oder
Anhaltspunkte nicht berücksichtigt,
weil das das Softwarefehler macht.
Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass jede Buchhaltungssoftware Fehler macht.
Und jetzt in der Regel halt hoffentlich welche zu unseren Gunsten oder so.
Bankirrtum zu ihren Gunsten, ja.
Ja, also und da, das ist also, das wurde da jetzt halt offenbar,
sagst du, darum wird ja auch wahrscheinlich diese Doku eher gehen,
wer da die Fehler gemacht hat oder wer die Fehleraufklärung verhindert hat.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen, aber ich denke mal, das dürfte auch in die Richtung
gegangen sein, mal aufzuzeigen, was es für Konsequenzen hatte.
Also einerseits, was es für Konsequenzen für diese Leute hatte,
aber auch was es für keine Konsequenzen für die Leute hatten,
die im Prinzip alle Informationen gehabt haben, um zu bewerten,
dass da mal was schiefgelaufen ist. ist.
Accountability, also das ist
halt der eine Aspekt, also einfach der Verantwortlichkeit an der Stelle.
Andererseits kann man sich natürlich auch fragen, inwiefern ist die Software
so gebaut worden, um solche Fehler auch zu verhindern.
Wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie Softwareentwicklung im Bereich der Raumfahrt funktioniert.
Also Voyager 2 und Voyager 1, die fliegen jetzt seit den 70er Jahren.
Software, die irgendwie uralt ist, auf uralten Computern läuft.
Also die unter den krassesten Strahlungsbedingungen, die man sich nur vorstellen kann,
irgendwie laufen muss und die permanent gepatcht wird und Dying-Hardware muss
immer wieder berücksichtigt werden und alles muss die ganze Zeit getrimmt werden
und trotzdem funktioniert es.
Und das funktioniert halt unter anderem auch deshalb, weil die Leute,
die das entwickelt haben, in dem Bewusstsein das getan haben.
Dass sie eigentlich sich Fehler nicht wirklich erlauben können,
beziehungsweise wenn die auftreten, diese auch in irgendeiner Form erkennen und abfangen müssen.
Weil wenn das Ding futsch ist und irgendwie in die falsche Richtung fliegt und
die Antenne sich nicht mehr gegen Erde streckt,
dann ist halt einfach Schluss und die ganzen Vorbereitungen und die Jahrzehnte
Arbeit und Planung und so weiter und diese einzige Gelegenheit, die es damals gab,
wirklich diesen Kurs zu machen, der an allen Planeten vorbeiführte,
ist dann halt einfach weg.
Und ein ähnliches Mindset würde ich mir eben manchmal auch bei kommerzieller Software wünschen,
die halt einfach den Fehlerfall immer wieder mit berücksichtigt und sagt,
okay, wir müssen hier Accountability, Überprüfbarkeit unseres Handels,
Rückgängigmachung von Fehlern beziehungsweise mindestens die schnelle Erkennbarkeit
dieser Fehler von vornherein im Design mit einbauen.
Einfach auch, weil es nicht unbedingt immer so ist, aber sein sollte,
dass man eben unter Umständen auch dafür haftbar gemacht wird,
dass die Software eben solche Fehler auch begeht.
Ja, er war mal ganz ehrlich.
Glaubst du, also was ist komplexer? Ja, so eine Raumkapsel da mal irgendwie
dauerhaft auf dem korrekten Kurs zu halten oder die Buchhaltung von so einem Post Office? ist.
Ich würde sagen, da ist die Raumfahrt ein gewisser, also die Frage ist immer,
wie viel Mühe gibt man sich und,
wenn du weißt, du kannst irgendwie deine Computer jederzeit tauschen und kannst
die Software jederzeit updaten und du hast so unmittelbaren Zugriff,
dann führt das natürlich zu einer ganz anderen,
Herangehensweise und wir wissen ja auch, wie sehr Software immer so ein Bloat
auch erzeugt und einfach mit Ressourcen schweinisch umgeht und sich eigentlich
um keine Rahmenbedingungen so wirklich kümmert, weil das kann man dann irgendwie
alles noch später fixen.
Und das sind einfach so Sachen, die in der Raumfahrt einfach,
weil das Objekt dann weg ist und sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr teuer war und du nur
eine Chance hast, die genutzt werden muss,
liegt einfach ein ganz anderer Schwerpunkt auf dieser Vorbereitung all dieser ganzen Probleme.
Also die werden sich ein bisschen mehr Mühe gegeben haben.
Da wird einfach ganz anders drüber nachgedacht. Da ist jeder einzelne Schritt,
jedes Kommando wird tausendfach,
beleuchtet und wird immer wieder durchgerollt, was kann hier alles schief gehen,
wie können wir, wenn was schief geht, das in irgendeiner Form mitigieren.
Da wird ein Assessment gemacht, was kann diese Maßnahme jetzt bewirken.
Man sieht das ja auch mal so schön, wenn mal wieder was schief geht.
Bei Voyager ist da auch ein gutes Beispiel.
Alle Nase lang hast du ja wieder so Meldungen, Voyager 1 meldet sich nicht mehr.
Oder was jetzt zuletzt war, Voyager 1 schickt auf einmal unerklärliche Nachrichten.
Ja, sie haben halt zwar noch Pakete empfangen, aber da war halt irgendwie so binär Müll drin.
Dann ist da so richtig Alarm. Da setzen sich dann irgendwie die ganzen klugen
Köpfe hin und grübeln mal ganz hart darüber nach, was jetzt hier das Problem sein kann.
Und wenn sie dann dieses Problem meinen, gefunden zu haben, dann gibt es nochmal
eine genauso intensive Phase mit, okay, und wie beheben wir das?
Und wie testen wir das, dass das, was wir jetzt da updaten, nicht die Sache noch schlimmer macht?
Und die haben ja einen extrem guten Track Record, weil ich meine,
die halten das Ding jetzt seit Jahrzehnten da oben.
Zugegeben, das ist jetzt alles nicht so komplex. Und auch wenn man sich so Software
der Mondlandefähre und so weiter anschaut, das ist, sagen wir mal,
mit dem Umfang, den Software heutzutage hat, so nicht vergleichbar.
Aber am Ende ist Buchhaltung dann doch im Wesentlichen … Keine Paketenwissenschaft.
Ja, es ist einfach, im Wesentlichen ist es Plus und Minus. Und sie haben halt
Plus und Minus nicht auf der Kette gekriegt.
Und ich finde, da kann man sich schon noch mal ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben.
Also Plus und Minus verwechseln in der Regel katastrophale Konsequenzen.
Ja, das sollte man wissen. Da muss man hingucken.
Und ich meine, es sind komplette Missionen. Ich meine, es sind Raketen auf dem
Mars zerschellt, weil sich dann später rausgestellt hat, dass dann doch einer
irgendwie mit Inch und Miles gerechnet hat. Planetenwahn.
Ach so, 8 nicht 9.
Scheiße. Fuck.
Sie haben halt einfach das Imperial Measurement System irgendwo verwendet so
anstatt das metrische System und dann war halt einfach die Berechnung falsch
so und dann sind sie halt auf die Oberfläche geknallt so und das sind halt solche,
Konsequenzen, da muss man halt drüber nachdenken, also Planung ordentlich machen
und so das geht auch, das ist etwas,
das kann man von Softwareentwicklung verlangen, dass Leute sich für dieses Assessment-Zeit
nehmen und ich finde Unternehmen,
die solche Software beauftragen, sollten dann sich auch diese Zeit nehmen und
sowas auch absichern, damit eben solche Sachen nicht passieren können.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Brandschutz.
Das ist halt auch immer die Frage, wie viel investierst du jetzt in Brandschutz?
Und ist das irgendwie okay, da irgendwelche Drainagerohre in deine Brandschutztüren,
reinzuhängen? Weil dann schließen die halt nicht mehr so richtig.
Nur solange es nicht brennt.
Naja, aber wenn es dann halt brennt.
Niemand die Absicht, dass es hier brennt.
Ja, aber das brennt dann halt manchmal trotzdem so und dann ist es halt so ein
bisschen scheiße, weil dann sind die Leute halt tot.
Wir wollen ja kein Feuer legen, wir wollen ja nur das Drainagerohr durch die Brandschutztür.
Ja.
Da wurden jetzt irgendwie Millionen ausgezahlt, aber an hunderttausende Menschen
oder so, also de facto mal wieder so eine ja, sucks to be you, your life was ruined.
Ja, aber hier hast du zumindest Geld. Also ob es schon ausgezahlt ist, weiß ich nicht.
Es wurde ihnen zugesagt. Das habe ich jetzt nicht im Blick gerade,
aber ich schätze mal, das wird irgendwie stattfinden, sofern die Leute noch
leben oder noch was davon haben.
Tja.
Größter Justizirrtum des Landes?
Also ich würde mal sagen, bestimmt der größte Justizirrtum des Landes,
der bisher bekannt geworden ist.
Da kommt noch was.
An Irrtümern ist Großbritannien generell nicht arm.
Irre, ey. Meine. Also ja, es ist Wahnsinn.
So, dann lass mal hier weitermachen. Wir haben ja noch eine andere Gesamtrechnung aufzumachen.
Ja, und zwar gibt es seit längerer Zeit den Begriff der Überwachungsgesamtrechnung.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen informiert, wo der herkam.
Mir ist dieser Begriff zum ersten Mal untergekommen beim Vorratsdatenspeicherungsurteil 2010.
Da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt,
hier so sinngemäß, es muss eine gesamte, also jede Überwachungsmaßnahme muss
im Kontext aller anderen Überwachungsmaßnahmen,
die ermöglicht werden, gesehen werden.
Ja, und so sinngemäß, wenn ihr jetzt hier eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung macht,
dann könnt ihr euch aber demnächst die ganzen anderen Überwachungsmaßnahmen langsam mal streichen.
Und jetzt ist natürlich über die Zeit eine ganze Reihe dazugekommen an Überwachungsmöglichkeiten,
die jetzt erstmal grundsätzlich dem Staat eingeräumt werden.
Die werden immer so getrennt diskutiert. Und die Idee der Überwachungsgesamtrechnung betrifft...
Quasi diese Überlegung zu sagen, irgendwann ist ja mal genug und wenn du jeweils
nur diese Einzelüberwachungsmaßnahmen diskutierst, dann kommst du potenziell
am Ende zu einer Massenüberwachung, weil du immer nur diese einzelnen Maßnahmen diskutiert hast.
Und 2010 in dem Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil kam das nach meiner Wahrnehmung
so zum ersten Mal in der deutschen,
in diesem Fall auch juristischen Debatte in einem Richterspruch zur Sprache.
Und keine 13 Jahre später wird dann tatsächlich mal der Auftrag von Seiten der
Bundesregierung erteilt, diese Überwachungsgesamtrechnung auch zu erstellen.
Diesen Auftrag hat jetzt das Max-Planck-Institut
zur Erforschung von Kriminalitätssicherheit und Recht bekommen.
Ja, das war im Koalitionsvertrag und sollte bis spätestens Ende 23 passieren,
wird also jetzt eher Ende 24 und im Koalitionsvertrag heißt es eine unabhängige
wissenschaftliche Evaluation der Sicherheitsgesetze und ihrer Auswirkungen auf
Freiheit und Demokratie.
Ja und jetzt gibt es, das soll also jetzt passieren,
von in diesem Fall unabhängigen Forscherinnen und Forschern,
die sich das mal anschauen und diese Überwachungsgesamtrechnung in dem Sinne erstellen.
Das ist, glaube ich, erstmal eine positive Nachricht, dass man sich aus dieser
Perspektive überhaupt mal dieser ganzen Überwachung nähert, weil das,
wie gesagt, in der Debatte auch immer wieder fehlt.
Und deswegen finde ich das eine positive Nachricht.
Ich glaube, Anna hat den Artikel geschrieben bei Netzpolitik.org genauso. Jetzt geht's los.
Die Fußballbezüge, das singt ihr doch auch immer im Stadion, oder? Jetzt geht's los?
Ab und zu mal ja.
Aber es ging in letzter Zeit nicht so los, von daher hat sich das nicht so ergeben.
Man muss erstmal wieder da sein, dann kann man auch losgehen.
Und mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt. Bin mal gespannt.
Mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt aus der Rechnung. Hoffentlich kommt dir da auch
mit dem Plus und dem Minus irgendwie klar.
Nicht, dass es ein folgenschwerer Fehler ist.
Sorry.
Ihr werdet überhaupt nicht überwacht. Die Überwachung ist negativ.
Wir müssen noch mehr Überwachung machen, um wir wieder auf Null zu kommen. Ihr schuldet uns Daten.
Wir werden die ganze Zeit entwacht.
Und dann gibt es noch eine eher traurige Entwicklung.
Wir haben das hier auch im Logbuch immer wieder begleitet,
dass die Maßnahme der Funkzellen über Abfrage, Wo also eine Polizei hingeht und sagt,
wir hätten gerne gewusst, welche MobilfunkteilnehmerInnen in einem gegebenen
Zeitraum in dieser Funkzelle eingeloggt waren.
Und dann wählst du natürlich deine Funkzellen so aus, dass die einen,
die sind ja in einem bestimmten Ort, du nimmst jetzt nicht irgendeine.
Und lässt dir dann einfach alle, die zu dem Zeitpunkt oder im angegebenen Zeitraum
in dieser Funkzelle eingeloggt waren, lässt du dir einfach geben.
Und ich glaube, die bekannten Fälle in Berlin, oder nee, in Deutschland, die...
Bei denen diese Maßnahme angeordnet wurde, waren einmal hier diese Autobrände in Berlin.
Da gab es so eine Reihe, lange Zeit, eine Reihe an, dass immer Autos gebrannt haben.
Das wurde, da war natürlich klar, das sind die Linksradikalen.
Und dann haben sie jedes Mal, wenn so eine Karre gebrannt hat,
Funkzellenabfrage gemacht und haben dann natürlich natürlich nach kürzester Zeit einen,
Mobilfunkteilnehmer identifiziert, der immer an diesen Orten war.
Das war irgendwie, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, irgendwie so ein gefrusteter,
Hartz-IV-Empfänger oder so.
Der war jetzt linksradikaler Bestrebungen relativ unverdächtig.
Aber haben ihn gefunden.
Und dann haben sie natürlich, oh, jetzt müssen wir das ganz viel machen,
dann wurde das auch mal in Dresden, denn in Dresden gibt es doch dann immer
da, Da gibt es auch immer so eine regelmäßige Nazi-Demo,
wo sie der Bombardierung der Stadt Dresden gedenken und das aber mit so ein paar Slogans tun,
die eher im geschichtsrevisionistischen Bereich anzusiedeln sind.
Und da gibt es ja dann auch immer große Gegendemonstrationen.
In dem Kontext gab es dann auch mal Abfragen.
Da war dann jetzt wieder der Fall, Moment mal, Demonstrationen,
ihr macht hier Funkzellenabfragen bei Demonstrationen, das ist ein riesiger Skandal.
Und dann gab es natürlich auch sehr viele Diskussionen um diese Maßnahmen und
dann wurde in Deutschland, in Berlin, in Berlin, jetzt nur Berlin,
Das Funkzellenabfragen-Transparenzsystem entwickelt.
Funktioniert so, du kannst dich da anmelden und sagen, hier pass auf,
wenn mein Telefon bei einer Funkzellenabfrage erfasst wird, dann möchte ich
darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werden.
Natürlich wirst du dann erst in Kenntnis gesetzt, wenn die Maßnahme abgeschlossen
ist und quasi keine Gefährdung für laufende Ermittlungen mehr stattfindet.
Mit anderen Worten, eigentlich wenn sie dann die Täter haben.
Weil vorher können sie ja immer sagen, nee, nee, Moment, wir können jetzt nicht
den Täter warnen. Ja, also das kannst du dir schon vorstellen,
dass du da relativ selten eine SMS bekommst.
Da musstest du dich anmelden und dann kriegst du so eine SMS und da musstest
du irgendwie, glaube ich, den Code eingeben, damit jetzt nicht irgendjemand,
Datenschutz kannst du jetzt nicht irgendjemanden da anmelden,
der das nicht haben will.
Und dann war aber das Skurrile, dass du so, ich glaube, drei oder sechs Monaten
kriegst dann so, deine Anmeldung läuft jetzt aus, du musst dich wieder anmelden.
Und der Hintergrund war, dass es ja theoretisch zumindest sein könnte,
dass du deine Telefonnummer abgegeben hast und die jetzt jemand anderes bekommen hat.
Oder vielleicht auch, dass du es nicht mehr willst oder du hast die SIM-Karte
jemand anders gegeben und der will das jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Und da gab es also irgendeine, da kam wieder irgendein sind,
sagen wir mal, im weitesten Sinne Datenschutz-Kram, der dazu geführt hat,
dass du dich immer wieder da neu anmelden musstest.
Natürlich relativ nervend und der Effekt, den so etwas hat, ist natürlich auch klar.
Irgendwann meldest du dich da, irgendwann vergisst du dich da wieder anzumelden. War bei mir auch so.
Ich war da, ich weiß nicht, ich habe da vielleicht drei, vier Erneuerungen gemacht,
und dann irgendwann gedacht, boah, Alter, ey, das nervt. Ich kriege eh schon
genug DHL-Phishing-Versuche, jetzt freu ich mich auch noch.
Naja, es setzt so eine Ermüdung ein.
So, aber die Berliner Polizei führt jeden Tag Funkzellenabfragen durch und sammelt
damit jedes Jahr, weiß ich nicht, 100 Millionen Datensätze.
Schreibt Netzpolitik.org, weil André Meister ist da ja in der Regel hinterher.
Jetzt wollte ich schon wieder hinten dran sagen. André Meister ist nicht hinten
dran, André Meister ist vorne weg.
Aber genau, der ist bei dem Thema hinterher. Und jetzt stellte sich raus,
dass diese Funkzellenabfragentransparenzsystem, das funktionierte gar nicht mehr.
Also wenn man sich da angemeldet hat, dann gab es, das hatte gar nicht mehr funktioniert.
Hat sich kein Schwein drum gekriegt.
Und hat natürlich auch keine Sau gemerkt. Und,
Jetzt ist es so, also irgendwie 2021, ich habe es ja hier noch liegen, das war der 26.09.21,
als hier die CDU gewählt wurde und damit wurde dieses System dann irgendwann aufgehört.
Ein halbes Jahr nach dem Amtsantritt der linken Justizsenatorin Lena Kreck,
die das Thema irgendwie so ein bisschen schleifen gelassen hat,
die Webseite war nicht erreichbar und die SMS wurden nicht mehr verschickt.
Und dann wurde angefragt, was ist da los?
Dann steht da so, ja, Hinweise auf Funktionsstörungen gingen ab Juni 2022 ein.
Ein exaktes Datum, ab wann der Service irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert hat,
können wir nicht rekonstruieren. Also die haben es einfach eben so,
keine Ahnung, funktioniert nicht mehr.
Hat da mal einer ein Update gemacht oder kein Update gemacht? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Oder hat mal jemand ein Testsystem eingebaut, was regelmäßig prüft, ob es noch läuft?
Genau, aber es hat aufgehört zu funktionieren und sie haben es dann nicht funktioniert.
Und jetzt wurde, jetzt ist also diese Infrastruktur kaputt und dann kommt die
CDU da her und sagt, oder CDU, SPD und sagt, ach komm, wenn das eh nicht funktioniert,
dann, das ist weiterhin gestört.
Wir reparieren das einfach nicht und die Justizverwaltung sagt ja,
da ist irgendwie Zuständigkeit ist unklar und wir haben kein Geld und jetzt wird einfach,
sagt man ja ist egal, lass laufen Hat sich ja auch keiner beschwert,
Wundert mich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass sich da kaum jemand beschwert hat,
weil also mich hat es ja wirklich interessiert aber mir war das dann irgendwann
auch zu blöd, mich da andauernd wieder neu anzumelden,
Ja, okay und jetzt hat das Abgeordnetenhaus mit den Stimmen von CDU und SPD
das Geld für den Betrieb des Systems vollständig gestrichen im Oktober und jetzt
werden die Betroffenen auch nicht mehr informiert,
obwohl das nämlich eigentlich gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist,
dass man darüber informiert werden muss und zwar seit 2017.
Tja, ganz geil.
Da kann man sich ja bestimmt drauf verklagen.
Da könnte man mal klagen. Stimmt eigentlich.
Ja, wenn es vorgeschrieben ist und es wird nicht getan, dann ist es ja Vereitelung
im Amt oder keine Ahnung, wie das dann heißt.
Hat bestimmt keine Konsequenzen.
Was sie natürlich weiterhin machen, sind die Funkzellenabfragen.
Eigentlich müsste man sagen, oh, wir können nicht mehr Transparenz dafür schaffen.
Dann dürft ihr auch keine Funkzellenabfrage machen.
Können wir auch keine Funkzellenabfragen machen.
Stimmt. Das wäre ja nicht eine richtige Strafe.
So, dann finde ich noch sehr schön, also wir berichten ja auch regelmäßig über
Neub, None of Your Business,
die NGO, die Max Schrems gegründet hat, die sich primär eben mit der Umsetzung
von DSGVO-Anforderungen bei den großen Unternehmen, denen die es halt auch irgendwie,
Oder zumindest bei großen Konzernen auseinandersetzt.
Und jetzt hat ja Facebook im November 2023 eingeführt,
dass es einen Bezahl-Service gibt, der ohne Tracking und ohne Datenverwertung funktioniert.
Und das ist ja der Trick, mit dem auch Nachrichtenseiten oder Presseerzeugnisse,
bei mir sind es halt meistens Nachrichtenseiten, die DSGVO-Einwilligungen erzwingen.
Oder willigst du ein, dass du getrackt wirst?
Und die Neub sagen halt, was ich sehr schön finde, dass sie halt sagen, das ist pay or okay.
Ja, also wir haben es ja auch schon mal besprochen als der Nein-Button mit dem
Preisschild dran. Und bei Facebook ist das offenbar so, du musst bis zu 251,88 Euro zahlen.
Ich glaube, das ist verbotlich Instagram und Facebook gemeinsam.
Pro Jahr.
Pro Jahr, genau.
Also 20 Euro im Monat sozusagen.
Ungefähr, oder etwas über 20. Ja.
Ja, und genau, jetzt hat Neub natürlich da eine Beschwerde eingelegt und sagt,
das ist ein klarer Rechtsverstoß und hat jetzt in Österreich eine Beschwerde
eingereicht bei der österreichischen Datenschutzbehörde.
Datenschutzbehörde und die soll Meta jetzt anweisen, seine Datenverarbeitung
mit dem europäischen Datenschutzrecht in Einklang zu bringen,
sodass sie und die Nutzerinnen eine einfache Möglichkeit zu geben,
ihre Einwilligung nicht nur nicht zu erklären, sondern auch zu widerrufen und
ohne, dass man dafür eine Gebühr bezahlen muss.
Finde ich sehr schön. Wir sagen auch, das wird natürlich von der österreichischen
Datenschutzbehörde wahrscheinlich an die irische Data Protection Commissioner weitergeleitet.
Und dann werden wir mal schauen, wie die mit ihrem Pay-or-Okay weiterkommen.
Max Schrems ist wirklich der Schmerz im Arsch von Meta Das ist schon wirklich
gut Also eine andere Sache, pay for your rights finde ich auch,
also die haben auch den richtigen,
Punkt oder die haben auch das richtige Framing dafür und sagen halt so,
der Gesetz sieht vor, so und so und ja machen sie,
Das ist schon schon ganz gut Ja und auch in der Regel sehr erfolgreich, was sie machen.
Ich kann mich gar nicht daran erinnern, dass sie irgendwann schon mal was verloren hätten.
Das ist halt das Geile, dass diese Facebook-Leute, die haben ja nun wirklich
alles Geld der Welt und mit Sicherheit mindestens die teuersten,
vielleicht sogar die besten Anwälte,
die man aber eben halt nur für Geld kaufen kann.
Und bei Neub sitzen halt so Max hat sein Jurastudium beendet,
ist halt auch ein Jurist und die sitzen da mit einem sehr viel geringeren Budget
Sagen wir mal, budgetmäßig,
sollte klar sein wer die Diskussion gewinnt Das ist schon,
wirklich ähm.
Tja, Motivation schlägt Budget.
Ich glaube vielleicht auch einfach so, die Gesetze wirklich befolgen zu wollen,
schlägt halt auch, also die Gesetze nicht umgehen zu wollen,
sondern einfach zur Anwendung zu bringen.
Da hat natürlich ein Neubner eine etwas leichtere, etwas bessere Position.
Trotzdem erfordert das natürlich eine ganze Menge Motivation,
in so einer NGO zu arbeiten.
Man könnte ja sich auch einfach für Meta verkaufen und seine Expertise sozusagen
der anderen Seite zuzuführen, aber offensichtlich gibt es noch genug Leute,
die da Sportgeist haben.
Ich finde das ohnehin sehr schön, wie wir so in den letzten Jahren so rechtsorientierte
Aktivistengruppen haben. Ja, frag den Staat.
Also die rechtsorientierten gefallen mir eigentlich weniger.
Sagen wir mal Jura-orientierten.
Ja, okay, sorry. Ich glaube mit Deutlichkeit des Begriffs.
Also die mit dem Recht arbeiten sozusagen. Man kann halt einfach auf die Straße
gehen und zu seinen klassischen Slogans in die kalte Luft schreien.
Das ist auch manchmal ganz okay, aber führt halt auf Dauer nicht unbedingt zum Ziel.
Aber in einem Rechtsstaat dann eben auch einfach mal den Rechtsweg zu beschreiten,
um Recht zu erlangen, ist keine schlechte Idee, erfordert aber natürlich die
entsprechende Kenntnis dieses Rechtssystems.
Und das beweisen wir beide ja regelmäßig wieder, ist nicht so breit gestreut,
so in der allgemeinen Bevölkerung.
Aber halt findige Juristen kriegen das halt ganz gut hin.
Und ja, wenn ich mir so anschaue, was fragt den Staat, was die GFF und jetzt
auch Neub so erreicht haben und noch erreichen werden, das kann sich schon sehen lassen.
Ja, fragt den Staat. Das ist so geil. Ich hab da jetzt wieder das mitbekommen,
dann wurde fragt den Staat ja irgendwie aberkannt, dass sie Presse sind.
Da wurde gesagt, ihr könnt euch nicht aufs Presserecht berufen,
weil ihr habt kein Druckerzeugnis.
Haben sie Druckerzeugnis erzeugt?
Fragt den Staat.de, das.de steht für Druckerzeugnis. Zack, haben sie eine Zeitung
gedruckt. Dann haben die gesagt, ihr habt ja nur eine gedruckt.
Okay, dann druck mal eine zweite. weiter.
Die sind auf dem Kongress verteilt worden.
Oh, das ist so geil.
Ja, das ist schon sportlich. Das ist bester Hacksport.
Ach, Arne, sagt er auch hier auf diesem A New Hope, sagt der Arne dann so. Ja,
häufig gibt es so eine Situation, wo ich eigentlich denke, ich habe eigentlich keine Hoffnung mehr.
Und dann schlägt wieder irgendwas fehlt und ich bin enttäuscht und dann denke
ich, ach krass, ich hatte ja doch noch Hoffnung.
Toll, ja. Also genau. Spendet an Frag den Staat und Neub und,
kauft unsere Shirts.
Spendet all diesen Organisationen gleich, nachdem ihr uns gespendet habt.
So, gut, jetzt haben wir aber hier schon wieder ganz gut Zeit.
Das muss ja auch noch geschnitten werden.
Man merkt wieder, wir waren nicht gut vorbereitet.
Ja, man braucht ein bisschen Anlauf. So im neuen Jahr, dann muss man sich ja
erstmal wieder finden und so.
Aber nächste Woche sind wir dann auch wieder bei euch und dann werden wir,
auch nochmal Interessantes zu bieten haben, aber jetzt wünschen wir euch erstmal
noch noch einen schönen Tag, Nacht, Abend, was auch immer gerade als nächstes ansteht bei euch und,
ja, würde ich sagen, wir verabschieden uns mal langsam, oder? Was meinst du?
Ja.
Gut. Dann machen wir das, Leute. Also, wir hören uns dann demnächst wieder.
Freuen uns schon drauf. Bis bald.
Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.